[Music]
you made it weird with pete holmes
what's happening weirdos another
wonderful weirdo wednesday here with sam
levine from freaks and geeks freaky
geeky as i like to call it also just a
delightful human being and a wonderful
podcast guest filled with wonderful
stories jokes attitudes anecdotes
altitudes he's great let's get to it as
quickly as possible not too much to plug
up top here
i do have a monthly largo show if you're
in the los angeles area and want to see
me do stand-up uh the last one the day
this came out so the show would have
been yesterday had bill burr spill burr
come on bill burr incredible always
always always always great go to largo
dash la.com and look for pete homes
living at largo hope to see you at those
shows it's always awesome to have
weirdos out there and i have a couple
other live dates coming up i'm going to
be in montreal for the just for laughs
fest we're going to be doing a live
podcast there and i'm also going to be
at the just for last fest in cancun
mexico november 2 through 6th of this
year go to pollen p-o-l-n-e-n.c
for more on that that's going to be fun
we'll also be dealing live podcasts at
that as well and if you like the show
why not show some support and try one of
the pete's picks like meundies what me
undies am i wearing blue plaid
blue plaid me undies let me ask you
something are you still trying to make
plans uh with you this summer as if you
aren't booked and busy already you're
gonna have to tell them to try again in
the fall you've got pool days pride
parades bachelor parties and beach
vacations waiting for you it's a lot but
thankfully me undies wants to make this
summer the most comfortable one you'll
never forget because when you're living
your best life the last thing you want
to worry about is butt sweat a bud sweat
hashtag butt sweat i heard about
meundies on another podcast years ago
and valerie and i both did a complete
underwear and loungewear overhaul my pj
pants my undies i love the colorful
prints i don't go for the plain ones i
go for the colorful fun ones because i'm
a colorful fun guy and i haven't looked
back i absolutely love them so when
you're comfy and feeling good you know
you're more present to enjoy all of your
summer plans it's like science or
something meandes has the lightest and
most breathable fabrics to keep you cool
and comfortable wherever you go i can
attest to that it's a very breathable
undie from undies bralettes and socks to
loungewear and swimwear you can find
something for all your plans miandi's
also releases new prints all the time
like their limited edition pride
collection you can match with your
partner your friends or even your dog
find your ultimate summer summer comfort
in sizes extra small to four xl and
meundies has a great offer for weirdos
for any first-time purchasers you get 15
off for a limited time if you sign up
for their free to join me on these
membership you get 25 off your first
membership item so to get 15 off your
first order 25 off your first membership
item and 100 satisfaction guarantee go
to meundies.com
weird that's meundies.com
weird and show your support of this show
second up
it's been a pete's pick for the longest
time it is alpha brain alpha brain is a
new atropic pneuotropic nuotropic which
is basically a vitamin for your brain
it's like fish food for your noggin it
helps with memory it helps with focus in
my personal experience it helps very
much with creativity whenever i'm doing
a podcast like this one or i'm guesting
on someone else's podcast if i'm writing
a script if i'm doing stand-up or if i'm
just going out to a party and i want to
have full access to my brain i just take
two or three alpha brain 15 minutes
beforehand it is not a stimulant it's
probably the thing i turn on people
to the most just in my regular life
because they see me taking it i was i
was shooting something today i popped a
couple in that were in my pocket people
always go what is that they want to know
and i tell them it's not a stimulant
it's not like caffeine it doesn't get
you all jacked up it just gives your
brain the earth-grown nutrition
earth-grown nutrition that it needs to
function and what what wouldn't be
better in your life if your brain worked
a little bit better i don't understand
why all people aren't just taking this
it's made my life so much better and if
you want to try it to see if you like it
if you like it one tenth as much as i do
you're gonna [__] your pants go to on
it.com slash weird you'll get 10 off
everything you see on that page
including alpha brain i like it in the
instant powder uh which is flavored i
also like it in the pills sometimes i
just pour the powder directly into my
mouth because it gets into my blood
faster that's how much i love it so go
to onnit.comweird show your support of
the show and see if it'll change your
life like it did to me last but not
least everlane boom i didn't even plan
this i'm wearing my everlane everyday uh
just classic gray sweatshirt i love
everlane they make some of the best
looking best fitting highest quality
clothing i've ever owned in my life and
i love love love how transparent they
are with their factory process practices
they're very ethical they're very moral
beautiful company and also they're very
careful when it comes to plastic because
you may be careful about the plastic you
use in everyday life i know a lot of us
are but it's easy to overlook the
plastic from synthetic materials in our
closets everlane has made it 90 of the
way to having no new plastics in their
entire apparel footwear and packaging
supply chain and to combat that last 10
percent that currently doesn't have
quality alternatives they've created the
next collective that's a fellowship
program to boost innovation for ending
new plastics in the fashion industry so
that means a hundred percent of their
shipping packaging is made from either
recycled plastic or fsc certified paper
97 of their apparel materials containing
polyester and nylon are made from
certified recycled fibers and more than
one million pounds of nylon and 9
million plastic bottles have been
recycled their new fellowship program
brings diverse perspectives together to
clean up the fashion industry this year
they've given a million dollars in
grants to entrepreneurs working to
reduce new plastics so what i'm talking
about they make incredible clothing but
it's feeling looking good and feeling
good about looking good i love
supporting them applicants were
considered based on their long-term
potential community impact and
collaboration and each fellow kept
ownership of their ideas and received 20
000 to advance their project projects i
love their stuff it's great to have them
if you want to support the show and want
to look good while you're doing it give
everlane a try be a part of the movement
for more sustainable clothing go to
everlane.com
weird and sign up for 10 off your first
order that's 10 off your first order
when you go to
everlane.com
weird and sign up all right everybody
hope to see you in montreal hope to see
you in cancun or maybe i'll see you here
in los angeles in the meantime try it
pete's pick and enjoy sammy the machine
levine
get into it
so many jews
somebody thought i was jewish
two nights ago don't say it like that i
could be fl i could be flavored
i could be flavored what is the jewish
holiday where they stop you on the
street and they go are you jewish i
won't do the voice you know the voice
what's the holiday of a pogrom
crystal knocked is when they [__]
stop you on this no are you you're a bad
jew i'm gonna out-jew you this whole
time
is it sukkot i know how you start the
show so i hope we're rolling up yes
we're rolling on this we're called out
on for what's the holiday where they
stop you on this there is a holiday yeah
it's called nazi germany show us your
papers are you jewish that's 30 seconds
to a holocaust 30 seconds to holocaust
that's that's jared leto's new band 30
seconds well that's to mars
30 seconds to holocaust uh i just want
you to know you're free to put your feet
on the chair on the sofa you don't have
to take my shoes off you can also do
that it's very mr rogers can i sing it
please won't you be mine wait wait um
it's a beautiful day in the neighborhood
a beautiful day for a neighbor
could you be mine wouldn't you be mine
won't you be my neighbor
there's another but then it goes it's a
beauty it's a neighborly day for a
beauty would and it's something like
that a neighborly day for a beauty
would you be mine could you be mine
won't you be
my neighbor he says it like it's your
secret he is my neighbor you know what
that means my neighbor hi neighbor i i
don't i just finally pulled my phone out
of my pocket
i laughed like a bully like
but i didn't mean it like that i meant
like i've done that many a time
save me the machine
is that precarious is that going to
bother you
remember blues traveler of course
i used to have a joke it's not great but
i'd go did that guy butter is harmonic
because it was it's is that okay
he knows he's strong
he lost all the weight he did lose all
the weight he and he still butters them
because he did keto like butter's not
even
butter's not even off the table for many
many uh
thin
wow this is about you've really what are
you saying
yeah i know but i'm a soft baby i feel
like i'm allowed
i think we should all be allowed as long
as you're we're not being mean about it
it's intense salmon oh it's all about
intense all about the benj intense
vengeance
i'll try and think of a movie trivia
question to make you feel at home okay
uh
what
yep where
uh christian bale
uh
holds a chainsaw
uh that's from the year 2000 and it's
american psycho 2 000. yeah directed by
mary herron
there you go clink
sure
actually we're not really going to do it
but then i remember we were rolling now
so really
uh they do call that docking if you have
a foreskin if you do that's i love that
you know about that you're a you're a
heterosexual cis male 1 yes straight sit
well yes so yeah you can say straight or
heterosexual okay yeah uh uh yeah though
as a word sounds like into your own
does it homo sounds like you're into
others i'm homo oh my god like you're
into it
something about hetero sounds pointed
inwards okay i mean it's towards your
own well it's the latin of it so it's oh
look at you well no it's you know hetero
hetero other homo is same
homogeneous sure heterogeneous
heterogeneous homogeneous uh
heterogeneous
hedonism
he had erogenism no
sammy the machine
look we're having our little we're
firing her out we're cleaning out the
the the grease pit on our burners oh man
outcomes he buttered his harmonicas out
comes 30 seconds to holocaust yep only
for you by the way uh and this really is
a sign of tremendous
respect would i ever be up and doing
something this early on a saturday when
i'm not on the clock okay on the clock
you are on the clock am i you are being
paid one magic mind
that's so good thanks left-handed nobody
caught it lefty
uh you don't have to i just got it
because you were drinking an uh a
caffeinated drink at least not you was
yucky let's not even talk about it i
won't even talk about it which rojo
male cow you were drinking
uh but uh and then i said do you want a
magic point and you said no and i was
like you're already drinking
petroleum it was
mostly jelly do you think the guy who
owns red bull looks at elon musk and is
like
like don't you think those are like
similar brands like we're going to the
moon we're going to jump from the moon
i don't think you understand the mission
statement of red bull really i don't
think they have illusions of going to
the moon no no red bull's always like
somebody's gonna
like bungee jump into a volcano red bull
i mean they that seems to monster these
things but i don't know that they're
coming up with the ideas elon musk is
sponsoring uh no he's like i want to be
a billionaire because i want to go to
mars you think he's sitting around being
like
i do i think elon musk is sitting around
i think right now
i was like he's a podcaster i'm not even
going to finish questions do you think
he's sitting around then i just turned
off yep yes i do you do you think like
like i thought about bill burr's bit
about how that steve jobs wasn't that
great which is the funniest take it is a
very funny bit obviously i i feel like
in his heart he probably doesn't mean it
but he's like
the point he makes is they're still
making him he's been dead
he's been dead for years they're still
doing it yeah and like there is a
criticism to be made of stephen jobs is
that he is the guy that's just kind of
asking the nerds i don't mean to point
to you asking the nerds no but asking
the nerds to design things and then he
looks at it and he's like it's a bit
bulky and then they're like
do you want to hear my only steve jobs
story and it has nothing to do with
actual steve jobs
now this is a story all about how i
don't know
we don't do that anymore
post slab we don't do that you can do
i'm the master rapper and i'm here to
say i love fruity pebbles in a major way
very similar
yellow orange purple lime and red but to
get the fruity taste i got to trick
fred fred you knew it i did um that i
used make sense i used to eat fruity
pebbles every day but wait a minute can
i tell you my bed please if you liked
fruity pebbles more than cocoa pebbles
did you i did you weren't hungry you
were thirsty
i've never had someone laugh at it
and i
it's
it means the truth has arrived on earth
like mana
it's here
okay
like that's the truest thing i've ever
thought like hungry boys wanted the
cocoa there's something sustaining about
the cocoa bubbles thirsty boys
i don't know what you're talking about i
just wanted a giant bowl of fruit you
wanted the colors i wanted the flavors
of lime and orange there's purple orange
and lime and red and the other one
i wanted a bowl of fruit that tasted
like crunch
lucky charms we're going to get to your
steve jobs story doesn't matter you
think we're not going to get to it i
know we will
build it up because it's not i'm not
going to story i'm here to make you
comfy
we're
we're this close to cucumber slices on
your eyes that's how that's how comfy
you're about to be fantastic remember
when lucky charms would be like red
balloons that like launched and launched
a new marshmallow
that was it was an ad campaign if you
watched saturday morning television you
knew that was our news it was i was just
saying it was like breaking news it was
our new pope like how do they smoke like
how they do [__] commercials now
that masquerade as like a news program
like a person would go and welcome back
to the show we're here with dr so-and-so
and it's something or whatever
i'm here to talk about this hair
regrowth thing right
that was like that but for lucky charms
like it might as well have had walter
cronkite breaking news from the lucky
charms desk yes this coming in from
lucky himself
red balloons red balloons by the way red
balloons what did they have an abundance
of red dye and circle shapes because
that's a [__] that has nothing to do
with luck or charm none whatsoever red
balloon they ran out of things that they
added rainbows they added horseshoes
horseshoes is good yeah hor sorry i
didn't mean to criticize no no i'm
you and i agree that horseshoes is okay
well it's one of the original horseshoes
is okay
luck has to do with and if they were
facing down in your spoon unlucky
unlucky charms it's true you know no
one's after your unlucky chop
can i just that's a great like kind of
like witchy t-shirt they're always after
me unlucky charms like if you're kind of
like a a wicked witch i know you were uh
originally a an east coast boy
but
but is that what we do sure but in the
uh tri-state area the new york new
jersey connecticut area in the 90s
that's hilarious i always thought the
tri-state was massachusetts new york
it's whatever you call it it's whatever
it is whatever it's recently it's
different per region as i've come to
learn
um anyway
there was a woman miss cleo oh yeah
remember that was clear call me now
and i would always try to do a misclear
impression but then it would always
morph into call me now for your free
reading and don't forget to try me
colorful lucky charms it was always in
the same breath call me now
it's hard it's hard to know if that's
okay
it's hard to know if i have to call miss
cleo to be like
can i do an impression of you that's why
i would call her
is it okay
in 2022 for me to do this i think it is
because i don't think that was her
natural accent either i am gonna throw
you a check for 300 000
because i couldn't agree more that woman
was like what's my name yeah miss cleo
sure how about
she's like that's ridiculous people love
mysticism i come from somewhere in the
caribbean undetermined a crab whispered
your future to me like on the beach you
just came up and was like buy amazon
if a crab whispered that to both of us
here's a question for you
you had
300 million dollars 300 million i'm
gonna give you 300 million
when you're 22. oh what a terrible idea
i know okay let's say 32. okay
would you be here
i don't mean alive i mean would you be
doing this podcast um because i have a
theory that that that amount of money
could be very much a curse i know that's
not like a hot take no it absolutely
could and i mean to to that degree or if
we're talking have you ever watched any
of those like the lottery rule in my
life kind of shows i have so then yeah
some guy with like a 7 000 haircut and
he's like
it's great to not worry about groceries
why this voice
but honestly i haven't seen my friend
janos
so so i guess i have to ask in this
version of the story do i have 300
million dollars and i didn't get it by
winning the lottery gross
i just wanted to say gross
not net i don't even know the difference
i kind of do uh you didn't win the
lottery okay because then that's a
matter of public record
because then every day of your life
people are asking you for money
very good yeah that's why we're doing a
thought experiment that's that's one of
the lottery ruin it is because in most
states it's a matter of public record
when you win a jackpot and they publish
uh whatever your last known address was
when you claimed can i tell you a movie
people write to you every day yes they
write to you they write you when they
show up at your home every day
you just have a department you pretty
much have to you could have like a
department so if you win hundreds of
millions of dollars in the lottery like
a multi-state lottery before you claim
the ticket you have to
uh set up a trust
to make it secret to make it well you
can't make it secret secret but you
basically set up a trust with a
different address and so that's the
address that goes on file right so
people are showing up to like
like a chick-fil-a
chick-fil-a yeah and you could you could
buy right to ask chick-fil-a for uh
they're religious
they have a lot of money and they do and
i'm sure they would be a tax shelter for
someone yeah
it's like the chicken soup for the soul
there was a there was one where somebody
asked like american airlines yeah for
like a free trip to see their dying
mother but it was like a very expensive
flight to like bali or something yeah
and the ceo i this story changed my life
oh it really did i was like 16 reading
chicken soup for the soul on my porch
and and the chapter is called thanks for
asking
and the ceo of american airlines said
yes
thanks for asking because once you're at
that level sometimes it's hard to get to
that person and that person just like
anybody has a need to give
for mitzvahs if you will okay what
hang up are you jewish
is it that holiday
it's not sukkot i'm telling you there's
a holiday they're very well made they go
around and say are you jewish and i
asked one of my uh other jewish friends
and they were like i thought you're
giving me the 90 minute light i was like
that is the fastest
episode of all time
let's not go back to that
uh so you would here's my movie pitch to
you to bring us back to that idea sure
uh you're you win the lottery yes you
have the ticket yes it's the opening
scene oh boy you're eating jiffy pop
you're eating lucky charms yep you're
sitting in your townhouse
uh that's a reference to something you
said earlier
off camera and you realize you won the
lottery and that's the biggest jackpot
of all time fantastic it's uh it's 700
million okay
you realize what you've you've seen the
lottery ruined my life documentaries so
you decide to give the ticket to your
friend
uh tim
to to
get it on your behalf sure then of
course tim
you know he's gonna double cross you
somehow oh boy because trouble because
no money mobile who wouldn't
700 million what wouldn't you do for 700
mil uh but go on i'm curious what you
think about the 300 million sam levine
because that's a great first question it
is a great first question i love your
question and people have a a pad answer
oh i just mean your follow-up question
like it's not public record you invested
in uber amazon oh brilliant and you now
have 300 million that no one knows right
but you
would you keep doing doug loves movies
this podcast would you
still be going out i would like to think
that i would only because
um
i've always been a man of leisure
uh
is this a dose of keys commercial
i have always been a man of leisure what
do you mean by that you mean you you
don't want to take off pjs it what it
means is some people are they go stir
crazy with nothing to do some people
retire and then they don't know what to
do with themselves then they come out of
retirement yeah of course uh and i'm not
talking about you know a tom brady thing
i'm talking about like a 79 year old an
85 year old who's been working their
entire life i'm gonna retire and then
they get like a year and they go i'm
going nuts here yeah i gotta find
something to do every day
not me
you that is not
the movie office space you're peter man
i i to a degree you would like to do
nothing i would i don't say nothing i
understand but i want you're capable i'm
capable of unplugging of doing very
little yes in a day yes and being very
okay with that tell me your strategy
i mean it in like in real life or in the
fantasy why do i'll tell you a little
bit about my the way my brain works
because i'm a little uh it's a running
joke on this podcast if i have a dd i
don't think i do uh but it doesn't
matter i'll just tell you about how my
brain works okay if i'm doing something
like this podcast i'm doing it yes and
that's one of the reasons i like you can
enjoy a day of nothing sure because i am
now doing nothing like i don't have that
restless leg
syndrome in my brain that's like but i
could go to the top of that mountain i'm
just like
vowel is more activity-based she'll be
like we should go to the top of that
mountain when i get to the top of that
mountain and i love it i'll love that
what what do you think is you're
why are you able to are you you could
sit on the beach
i'm not personally i'm not really a
beach guy okay yeah yeah i stay out of
the swimming pool
vampire complex i understand yeah no i'm
afraid for my neck safety not my body
just my neck uh so what what is a
nothing day for you um a nothing day i i
love baseball bebo uh well you say
bieber i think most people think
basically no no remember yeah yeah okay
okay i think b-ball is basically balls
baseball baseball
and boulia based too oh boy i'm making a
b-ball pasta wow people know that that
means
i had no idea you were so handy in the
kitchen um
uh i love baseball so a a day for me
where i'm doing
very little to nothing yeah i will watch
three baseball games in a day be very
happy yeah uh what is it an excuse to
eat and sip beer or are you just
watching baseball uh i can very happily
just watch baseball i mean i enjoy booze
but i've never
i i've never had that thing oh god i
wish i were drinking right now drinking
making so much better you've met my
cousin
if if a drink is there i'll have a drink
but i but you're not just like baseball
isn't the gateway drug team you're
eating of nachos uh no baseball is not
my gateway you just like baseball i just
love baseball and so i could watch what
do you do during the commercials uh pee
urinate
sorry
urinate doctor
i i will i will relieve my bladder
pressure in the bathroom properly
i used to think that was very funny when
i was a kid that you know like in uh my
so-called life
the first episode she's like um it's
gross that people chew in public yeah
and i remember that being very authentic
like when you're a teenager you have all
these ideas and you think you're the
first one to have them sure mine was i
think it's so weird that people are like
i have to go to the bathroom because
it's very personal to be like what
you're really saying is i feel
i feel pressure building in my my my
vajayjay
do people still say for gg oh productive
call me now
i don't can you say call me now
can we save a jj
princess for jj i oversaid it once and
remember uh the soup
mchale so uh she there was a clip that
they would run all the time where she
was up in like a harness hanging from
something
and she and literally she said and i
hope i'm remembering the quote right my
vajayjay is painin
is painin painin
well you just declared my netflix
password and i wish i wish you hadn't my
video i do it into the remote my va jj
is pain in a posture for you
it's gotta be a body there's no oh it's
letters n symbols no g there let me ask
you this you got a number or a letter
password for your phone um
it's unlocked it's uh no it's not
unlocked it's numbers okay it took me a
second because i there was a period
where it was alphanumeric and then we
all had to wear masks and so then i was
entering my password a lot more smooch
yeah what is the what's the password uh
it honestly would take me a second it's
one of those things where when your hand
is doing it yeah it's it's much
it's automatic i think my memory is the
one of the weirdest things in the world
it is crazy the minute you asked me and
i was like i'd have to write it down
somewhere it would take me
30 full seconds to go nope that is it
we always we all have
different series of numbers that we have
to remember for our various things my
alarm system when it's going off i often
just blank
and then i'm explaining to the police
that's not true they've never come but i
have been like
what is it i'm entering my atm i'm
entering my phone i'm entering
just i'm dialing 9-1-1 on the bad i
don't know what to do call they always
call your cell phone rings hi it's you
know westgate or whoever the company is
my security code is a very embarrassing
thing okay and i have to say it to these
people i think eugene people had i just
thought about this bit it's such a great
bit do you want to do it i i i'll be
i'll be
the mr merman i'm going to ask you
your security question is that okay yes
of course okay um
oh wait you asked the question i do ask
the question no i asked the question you
asked the question i have to give you
yeah okay um what are you
what are you wearing what an
inappropriate question yeah
his security question is they ask what
are you wearing and he says what an
inappropriate question and that's that's
when they turn the alarm off because it
was it was something you had to enter
where it was like they don't they didn't
have pre-selected questions you made
your own they allow you to suggest your
own questions truly special are you
wearing it truly i don't think that's
appropriate dear you what an
inappropriate question
um it's great it's truly wonderful such
a good bit um sammy yeah buddy what were
we just talking about i don't even
remember but um would you say keep a
good job story
no this is over oh it's over i'm just
kidding uh yeah i do want to see you
here i've never met steve jobs uh sadly
uh uh and so well then we can add you
never will meets that is
probably correct
elon musk with his yellow moons and pink
stars um they made two movies about
steve jobs biopics if you will i'm aware
the first one that came out ashton kutch
was ashton kutch and it was simply
called jobs jobs the second one was the
big one with fassbender and seth rogen
and which is called steve jobs you're
welcome we cast michael fassbender as
you big time like you that whole movie
i'm just like god damn it he's so
handsome yeah that whole time i'm like
was anthony edwards unavailable what are
we doing here by the way the staircase
how is that not the guy the mean doctor
from scrubs
john c mcginley
was born to play michael peterson and
they're like nah give it to the guy from
love actually
who's great but doesn't look like him
doesn't have the same right sort of
reptilian coldness that's true but i
don't think i think jobs was more
publicly well known what his face looked
like i think the staircase most people
have no idea but then when you image if
you image if you do it if you google
you watch it and you're like that's not
colin firth yeah for what it's first
that is not it yeah
nothing for what it's worth
oh there he is what a joyful laughter i
enjoyed it on the i kind of half heard
it the first time and then the second
time it was you going come on you got to
give me some my whole career is
hey i'm the same way i there is uh ricky
jay the late great ricky g yeah i love
ricky dude his came up
two episodes ago oh brilliant well here
he comes up again no there was we'll cut
it all out that's great uh there was a
his closing bit uh where he would throw
playing cards under watermelon a second
and that was referenced in a week but it
was his closer for for his whole act for
the last 30 years gallagher was like if
you like that
and he would throw it would throw it
into the watermelon into the fleshy part
uh the the inside part it would cut the
watermelon in half so it was the easy
one yeah and then he would throw a
playing card directly into the same
place yeah and his
uh line for that every time he did it
was
um
it should be noted that the last playing
card i have thrown went into the exact
same spot as the card before it a feat
so impressive i am forced to mention it
myself yeah
and i was like oh that's a great way of
putting hey i just did something
brilliant i hate that i have to be the
one to point out how brandon is but i'm
not gonna be okay with going on without
it is there a better definition for
magic
all of magic yeah i've i've never did on
stage but i always wanted to do a bit
that being very rich is like being a
magician okay because i pour you wine
and i go like this wine actually
belonged to saint francis of assisi it's
been aged for three thousand like you
have to explain why it matters and when
a magician has to be like and you'll
notice i set your watch to 12 noon and i
was i ever near you right you know what
i mean it's the same sort of what a drag
and that's what i feel like david blaine
was like if you have to explain it
that's why he started regurgitating
frogs and stuff because he was like if
you have to be like and that i do i've
done magic you have to be like and i
never went over there like you have to
walk them towards the amazement mm-hmm
it's not great i agree with you you need
to i would think if you're
if you find that you're constantly
explaining the impressive thing you just
did as a magician yes you need to work
on your act
or i would just revamp all of magic
because that's that's what we've learned
you want to do a rebranding a rebranding
i'm not saying ricky j was wrong to call
it out and that's a brilliant way to do
it yeah but like
i don't know
do we care i mean that's the question is
do we care that the card i saw his stage
show twice in person and i every time he
said that line it always gets a huge
laugh he did that on conan and did it
and did the line and it too there got a
huge life it's it's a good laugh line i
we were also talking about in and of
itself which did you see that not yet
derek delgadio but he does incredible
card i mean like really incredible yeah
like it's not exactly this but he
shuffles a deck and then he makes it all
red all black like perfect sequential or
like by shuffling yeah and sometimes
things are so amazing you actually don't
understand them and you do need someone
so i'm going back i'm now arguing the
other side i have to say that people are
too stupid to know what's that hard a
trick to do
pardon the interruption weirdos hey
guys it's time to bring that summer heat
into the bedroom that's right this
episode is sponsored by blue chew guys
confidence can take you far in life it
can also help in the bedroom especially
when it comes time to step up to the
plate talking about doing it and that's
where blue chew comes in blue chew is a
unique online service that delivers the
same active ingredients as viagra and
cialis but in chewable tablets at a
fraction of the cost you can take them
anytime day or night so you can plan
ahead or be ready whenever the
opportunity arises the process is simple
sign up at bluechew.com consult with
their online medical
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved you'll receive your
prescription within days the best part
it's all done online that means no
visits to the doctor's office no awkward
conversations and no waiting in line at
the pharmacy bluetooth tablets are made
in the usa and prepared and shipped
directly to your door in a discreet
package with blue chew men everywhere
excited to see the postman because when
your package has arrived god your
package has arrived do you get it your
package come on everybody they always
say the first impression is important
but what about lasting impressions it's
time to get off the couch and get back
to work if your tool needs an upgrade
head to bluechew.com
women say there's nothing sexier than
confidence and blue chew can help you
give you confidence where it counts so
if you could benefit from the extra
confidence when it's time to perform
blue chew can help and we've got a
special deal for our listeners try blue
chew free when you use promo code weird
at checkout just pay five dollars
shipping that's bluechew.com promo code
weird to receive your first month free
visit bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information and we
thank bluechu for sponsoring this
podcast
enjoy the rest of the show
boom
sammy yeah who are you talking to i'm
talking to you you could do that trick i
could teach you to do that trick in
about 90 minutes
sammy yeah
we're gonna i'm gonna talk to sam in
italian
he's a godfather
i'm gonna speak to sammy i'm italian
right now we're gonna talk magic right
now
i don't mean uh i mean like a random
like we're to shuffle a random card like
like i'm going to take a deck of cards
out i'm going to demonstrate that
they're randomized sure then i'm going
to shuffle them blind well you're not
going to shuffle them blind well i mean
i'm not looking it's going to look i'm
not looking but it's it's gonna look
like you're just
mashing them up you're throwing some
this way you're gonna throw some this
way i'm talking riffle shuffles riffles
ruffles yes
sammy yeah
neither of us are able to do that trick
i disagree
i i mean i just because i haven't seen
you so it's mechanics yeah so i haven't
seen the drake he may be doing a
different version of this but what
you're describing
a broadly is i know that trick you know
that trick
it's not that oh it's not
well i could teach you to do the one i'm
talking about i've done it okay
see
you see
where's my camera you see
those aren't running
jk
second time fads come up this week too
oh i said it all the time it's a great
one i say papa pup
no
i i thought that was uh perhaps yetis
it's when you if someone says like if
sammy's foot falls off and you go papa
it's your way of saying like oh god
forbid don't yeah god forbid are also
like i'm not asking don't even put it
out there yeah let's stop it from going
out there okay yeah go ahead so steve
jobs oh right mike michael fassbender
michael fashion good looking for steve
jobs way too good looking
too good looking for a man ashton
kutcher also too good looking for steve
jobs i agree but that movie was so bad
he actually became less handsome
i'm not even kidding yeah if you're like
the in the dumb steve jobs movie yeah
go am i moist
they kind of they're supposed to choose
they kind of evaporate and then fast
bender comes out and it's like
oh wow that's i never thought in the
world someone would add sound effects to
a drying vagina
a dehumidifier
a d identified that
asher in jobs was a dehumidifier
humidifier for the ladies
we can just say vaginas yeah these are
technical terms call me now we don't we
don't know we started off with holocaust
and mocking miss cleo
we could do anything sam or floating in
space man oh i was so excited to come
here today because i was like i know
what what conversations i tend to get
into when i do podcasts
but i have dehumanized no idea where
this is going to go today and i'm
really excited yeah
so far i'm not disappointed
i can't wait to get started i'm in the
bad steve jobs movie you what i am in
the bad steve jobs movie that's why i
tell this story
yeah yeah oh it's fine i've been
[__] on it it's fine
here's the reason i tell the story when
we talk about did you do one with ashy
yeah i'm in that movie you did you do a
scene with him i did with ashy yes so
you can say he was probably humidifying
i mean on the day beyond the day here is
what i will say he walked around with
the glasses yeah
and
stayed for better or worse in character
uh while we were not rolling it was it
was important to him
to to to stay in that space
as long as possible for the best
performance yes job space um
that's
being said
uh i
originally auditioned for that movie for
a different role i don't even remember
which one and you'd be a good wize
i will say this for as impressive as the
uh the the the fassbender jobs movie was
the cast on the kuchi one
it's pretty there's nothing to shake a
stick at i tried to watch it and it did
his lsd trip where he's conducting the
grains of like he's in a field and he's
conducting it and i was just like
i don't know why it's
doing the that sequence wrong it felt
wrong yeah
i have another thing to say but keep
going okay um so
i did the audition and i remember even
at my audition
realizing i'm so wrong for the role
they're asking me to read for and then
they had at the uh this is back in the
days when you'd audition in person they
had all the sides for all the other
characters laid out on the table
sometimes casting officers will have
that because they have multiple actors
coming in to read for multiple roles
people forget their side sometimes and
so i'm looking around and i see a
smaller part but the description is
right there i'm like oh this is a part i
could do yeah what did it say i don't
remember that sam levine type a sam
levine type short jewish we're not sure
if he's jewish hopefully someone will
ask him and so j
i
actually walked into the
audition and everyone was in the room
and i was like okay here's the part you
asked me to read for i don't want to
waste anyone's time here's the part i
just saw in the
waiting room can i read this instead
it's a smaller role don't tell my agents
they'll be angry with me are you guys
okay with that they were like yeah
so that's what i read for instead and
then i didn't hear anything like a month
and i thought oh well whatever i tried
and then they called and offered me a
third role a completely different role
not one of the ones that i wanted read
was supposed to read for the one i
actually did read for um and it was
apple designer number two and i was like
all right 82. uh no number two 80 number
two a.d number two uh and
it
it sounds like a you know it's not uh
great necessarily to play a character
that doesn't have a name but in this
particular instance they sent over the
script and he actually had
not a small amount of dialogue in uh
scenes in like two scenes
and then the second scene he's got quite
quite a bit
and uh and i thought oh well that's very
exciting and um
so i said yeah sure i'd be happy to do
it and so i got hired to work for two
days and uh we shot it up somewhere in
the north valley
and i get to set and we shoot it out of
order so we shoot my second scene first
where i'm really just in the background
uh and then
uh
i think we had the weekend i think it
was like friday and then i came back in
on monday and we're gonna shoot the bulk
of it the thing where i have a whole lot
of back and forth with jobs and um
we get called to set and we're doing a
little rehearsal of the scene and
there's a little bit of stuff before
jobs walks into the room a little bit of
business
and i'm not
and then i'm not i don't have much
business uh i have business when he
walks in and so there's some business
and then he walks in and you know we're
just doing a rehearsal for the director
and you know camera department and then
uh i'm waiting for the part where he's
supposed to address me and i'm waiting
and then all of a sudden he
jobs he
turns and does a different portion of
the scene like the end of the scene and
he just moves over there and then the
director in the camera person are just
following and i'm like ah
and i don't say anything you mean he
went completely out of order uh
completely out of order like skipped a
whole page the the page your page where
i have lines and stuff
and i was like oh surely this must be
mistake surely the director or the
script supervisor who is reading and
realizing that we've skipped a page of
dialogue surely one of them will say
something and uh so the scene ends and
the director's like okay that was great
and then he goes over to talk and then i
walk over to the script supervisor i'm
like did we just and she's like yeah
just give me a second i'll figure this
out and uh it's like okay i'm standing
there and i see
jobsie and the director uh they're
talking they're talking and she's
watching and listening and she looks
over me and she just goes
and i'm realizing that just
apropos nothing
either he or the director or whoever
they just decided as this bit is it's we
don't need it
it it takes the scene somewhere else we
don't need it uh so we'll just hide on
the fly they cut it on the fly so i
wound up having
a one line
apple super you had less lines than your
character's name truly and uh i was like
all right look i'm a big boy i've been
cut out of plenty of things yeah i've
been cut out of better joints than this
because so many things i was like look
that's fine
it didn't it honestly doesn't matter
whether they cut it now or they get to
the edit and they cut it there frankly
less work for me to do so i don't care
however fewer work for me to do thank
you
um
i don't care
i do however i hadn't yet signed my
contract it was still sitting in my uh
my little trailer i hadn't signed it on
friday and so i call my uh manager i
explained the situation i was like look
it's fine whatever it's not a huge deal
but i think i should probably go
uncredited in this movie what with my
one line of dialogue my name is
leave my name off just because i'd
rather it be a that way i can
it it's
it's the kind of thing where someone
will see me in the movie they'll look
for my name in the credits it won't be
there they'll second-guess themselves
they'll have to look it up it'll be one
of those weird things that like it makes
it a little more special for me lore
sure you want to be lord i would love to
be a little lure i'm unbilled and lost
ooh cashier in the final season you have
looked on the internet
um yeah so it's conspicuous on your
wikipedia page it says like
sam was friends with one of the creators
of lost
who kept saying i'll write something for
you on the show you're now you're
quoting directly from wikipedia well
citation no longer needed it's confirmed
i just said you're quoting from
wikipedia i've confirmed
a riffing man is understood to consent
[Laughter]
yes
anyway so i was like hey listen i
haven't signed this yet uh have them
print up a new one everything's the same
except i want no credit in the end
credit crawl and he was like uh sure so
he calls and they were like oh you sure
you sure was like yeah i'm sure just
fine
i i have to go back are you sure this
wasn't you being a little bit of a
stinker in a good way oh cause they kind
of like pooped on your on your sandwich
but but you're like you can poop on my
sandwich but you're not gonna make me
thank you i was definitely not thrilled
on the day i remember that no i've been
in your situation where someone jumps
your part right and it's not you know
like i said i've been cut out of things
so i'm always prepared for any work i do
on the day to be seen by no one sure but
that was the first time i think it had
happened where i was standing there
watching it unfold in real time we're
not even going to never been cut like a
play film yeah to shoot this yeah yeah
that wasn't shot on iphones
[Laughter]
and so i was like it's fine like
whatever but just don't kill me in it
you didn't think about it it'll be fun
for me i'll keep this job still i
actually really like that i think that's
a nice way to alchemize the and you're
like i'm going to turn this into lore
yeah and a story and so that's what i
would i asked for
so that's good
and
then
these are so hard to do in real life but
when they happen uh-huh very natural i
forgot about it
i forgot so i finished shooting the day
and then
my contract's in i finished shooting i
forget about it i move on with my life
um the movie comes out i did not see it
in theaters um
and several years go by
and i am on an airplane and it's like
2016 or something maybe
degrees on the airplane
and
uh
i
was
it was one of the flights where it gives
you cable or whatever sure and the movie
was playing on my screen
without me having touched anything oh
like i sat down in a seat on a plane you
were on ashton kutcher airlines there
was an astronaut airlines and that was
just the movie playing on the this
year's 70s show that's all yes
i
was kind of half awake half asleep when
it started
and i'm watching the movie and my hand
to god this is the only time this has
ever happened in my life
i forgot i was in that movie oh wow and
at one point he rounds the corner and
walks into this room and then there's a
shot of the room and i go
[__] that's right
wow
like i'd blocked it all out you cut
yourself off i cut myself out of that
you remember my brain wow and i was like
oh right he's what he was what's going
on here or why are you here and i have
my one line in the movie it's 11 a.m on
a wednesday or whatever it is and i was
like oh my god
oh my god like i had a moment yeah in my
seat on this plane yes i was like i am
not prolific i'm not successful by uh
like i'm not some actor who's my
mother's [__] my mother said i'm not
some actor who's been in like i'm not
sam jackson
250 movies and it's like oh yeah i
forgot i was in the no like this was the
weirdest sensation that had ever
happened to me can i
you're gonna like this well i have to
put the button on it no no okay
meundies.com i'm just kidding go on
go on that was a joke that's the place
to put it by the way
so i watched the rest of the movie i'm
like oh my god that's amazing and then
it all it all comes back to me what
happened the the thing and i want to be
on build and then i'm watching on this
little directv screen the tiny little
credits and i'm like oh and i forgot he
was in there oh and i forgot he was in
that
the [__] build me
apple designer number two sam levine
they ignored my contract but you said i
said
just like apple
you you probably signed a contract but
there's all this stuff about itunes and
privacy in there third-party apps
ask app not to track
ask film not to credit ask
and there's and i remember like i i was
i was pissed and i come and i was like
can we do something about that he's like
the film's four years old i don't know
what you want from me that's hilarious
that you tried i well it wasn't that's
like that's your pam and tommy sex tape
like we need to get it out they're like
it's already on the internet isn't that
uh
you know
a violation of an agreed upon contract
and he's like well here's the problem
there's always a clause in there about
crediting in every contract where it's
like failure to do the thing that we're
agreeing upon here uh on the on the
producer's side is not to be viewed as
intentional
i see so any similarity to people being
credited in this movie is entirely so if
they misspell your name in the credits
three m's there you go that that
i love that that's the mistake not one m
but three of them three m's which then
you know it's not one and a whole
corporation gets involved 3m corp gets
involved
and they've got money because of
post-its
who 3m
you are fun
and lisa kudrow who pretended to invent
post-its in the movie romee and
michelle's high school reunion which
came out 37 97 volcano they were in
theaters the same time i saw them both
in the same day volcano with tommy lee
jones and ann heesch
we gotta we gotta get this volcano out
of here i tried to i tried to think of
it with tommy lee jones you saw me we
gotta we gotta get this volcano out of
here
there's a volcano and it's about to blow
what what's the cheek thing i don't know
it always kind of feels like a kind of
like a he had do you think he had big
cheeks now no he's just sort of droopier
okay
there's evil out here i can't even i
can't even imagine you ever watch a
movie with tommy lee jones and it's like
20 years old and he looks really old
then and you're like
[__] you're 20 years old yeah yeah he
was old 20 years ago can i tell you a
great time really jones movie he's
starting to look like the other face
you've never heard of this movie it's
called rolling thunder
i have heard him okay it's him and
william devane and it's from the 70s
uh uh grindhouse movie okay and uh
it's super cool and it's badass and it's
one of the youngest tommy lee jones i've
ever seen and he's [__] intense in
this movie i love it yeah i also need it
check it out rolling thunder here's a
story that i think you're going to love
and i loved your story and i'm here for
you thank you uh i did try to cut it off
me and he's not coming
um
somebody i have this on good authority
but i don't want to say who told me the
story because i don't want to out them
that one time john malkovich was trying
to remember all the movies he was in
yeah he went like i was trying to
remember all the movies that i've been
in that i have been in i can't do it
today and he goes and i couldn't
remember them
even the weird one with my name in the
title
john malkovich the weird one with my
name in the title couldn't remember it
maybe he's talking about that jewel
thief movie
very good thank you
very good being john malkovich is very
sad there's a lot of movies that i i
can't watch there's something sad i
don't like john cusack and his bad
relationship and the woman with the
monkey in their little apartment and
then he's in love with catherine keener
and she's so mean to him
something about any and he's and he's
struggling on the street and he's not
understood
it's just too
it's hard it breaks my heart i'm just
like i just want to get that guy
craig a new life lottie and maxine it
takes sometimes i have to do that in my
head the characters character names yeah
what's the monkey's name elijah
[Music]
sorry are we winning a trivia night
right now you asked that was very good
what's going on with that kind of noodle
uh that's how my brain works i remember
photos everything in the movies
and some most of the tv some of the tvs
there's a lot of teams what what is
going on there uh i have uh like in
freaky geeky i always think of martin
starr okay eating the and laughing at
the
and was that you like why the emotional
ah bond to movies okay here we go it's a
couple of reasons what's this
what a power move it's a couple reasons
you're so loud my mic will pick you up
um it's uh it's
true so true
and the first one is the the great
reason the second one's the bummer
reason and then the third one's the
great reason uh the first reason is it's
like an oreo with [__] in the middle
don't eat that [__] just twist the twist
twist wash wash it definitely
throw the whole cookie out you're better
off
so you know what skip the story um
so the first reason is uh my parents
both are huge film people
cinephiles cinephiles i was raised in a
house
uh where i was yeah in a sin house i was
raised in a house of sin
uh where i was allowed to have a
television with
full
cable tv access i mean every channel
under the sun when i was 11 years old in
my bedroom you ever just get up to pee
at like 11 30 and just throw on cinemax
to see what's happening do you mean when
i got up to be at 11 30 and cinemax had
been on all night already do you think
at 11 30 i was like maybe now is the
time to turn it off no do you remember
when it would tell you the letters and
it would be like nudity and sexuality i
mean that came later but yes oh later
yeah that was not i couldn't tell you
when they started with the with the tv
ratings like but that became like why
you would watch a movie you had never
heard of yes it took the guesswork out
of
wtb
yep will there be a booby
you know it wouldn't say booby it would
just say this film contains nudity but
it was the 90s so it was definitely a
booby um
unless i was like aj
hurtin what might have a jj hurting my
vajayjay is painting pain and yeah yeah
hurting is my hulu password sorry
okay so my parents loved movies they had
an enormous collection my uh late
grandfather my mother's father he too
had an enormous collection of vhs tapes
and laserdisc and i was brought up with
a love of cinema wow and for the kids a
laserdisc is a dvd you could cook a
pizza on
it was the size of one it was the size
of like a perspective a personal pizza
you get like the frozen pizzas it's
actually
kind of a pizza you would get at a movie
theater oh very fitting yes yes that
maybe that's what they base the size of
those movie theater pizzas somebody's
like where should we print these things
i'll have a pizza we got
we got a lot of laser discs nobody wants
some we can use those to keep the pies
warm
that's what they're doing now that's
what they sure are you know how some
people would hang a cd from their rear
view i
sir you know you can't have the oh my
god 1984's dune
no it's copland we gotta watch it
maybe four is dude i don't think
[Laughter]
anyway so that's reason number one so
you yeah watching a lot cinematic action
cinephile cinemax [__] turner
classic movies all the movies
my folks said movies are important here
watch these movies we love these movies
before you get to the sad reason what
was do you remember the one movie that
you were not your favorite movie but the
first movie you watched and you were
like oh [__] movies can transport me
somewhere one hundred percent one
hundred and one hundred percent i can
tell you the movie 101 dalmatian it's
it's not just that it is my favorite
movie but for that very reason what is
a clockwork orange that was the movie
that i saw in my bedroom with this goofy
[__] tv that i had no business having
at it started at like one in the morning
on a school night uh twbab there will be
a boob there will be lots of boobies and
some dongs but also in a way that is
like upsetting oh very upset you're not
ready for upsetting sexuality when you
don't even have regular sexuality
correct you know what i mean i'm barely
ready for that movie now yeah no i was
like 11 maybe 12. yeah that's that's
when you want to see it it's the wrong
age two camera uh
right in there it was the wrong age but
in a good way it turned out to be the
right age because it changed the way i
saw movies i mean i'd seen i'd seen
movies with some kind of heavy stuff in
it i've never seen a movie like that i
did not think a story like that could be
told in a film yeah and let alone a film
that at that point was 20 you know five
years old no yeah old younger than that
i haven't seen it in a very long time i
i don't think i've seen that movie since
i would be capable of understanding it
does it this is a silly question does it
hold up is it still amazing
believe it is yeah yeah no i think it is
a
a kind of about mind control it's about
a lot of things it's i mean it's based
on a book which i then read by anthony
burgess um but it's
really hard book to read because it's
written in newspeak which is
how the the drugs speak to each other
how alex future
in the future yes do they speak in
newspeak in the movie they do
all i remember is ultra violence ultra
violence vidi well little brother
you know okay so the whole book even the
narrator clean tash took the red red
groovy soon stopped yeah these are all
wow
if i'm a producer i have one note
and it is
[__] cut it out
[Laughter]
yeah but it's in newspeak wow and the
narrator in the book is also like
sit down bravo gonna that's not even it
but tell me wait wait wait let me start
over calling me now
that was in the book
yeah uh even the narrator is speaking
and yeah alex the narrator oh it's in
his head yes how troubling well you
don't want to be in that head you don't
i mean alexander dillard so tell me
tell me a little bit what it's about
just because i want to i want clock
recording yeah yeah you're saying it was
about
a lot of things it's about a lot of
things but it's what's up
it's about the the decay of society and
the overreach of government uh to meddle
with things right and also like
i i i'm sorry this is stupid to burden
you with telling me what clockwork
orange is about sure but it seems to be
like all the holding his eyes open and
stuff like brainwashing like it seems a
little predictive
i think it's interesting how our phones
now tell us what reality is social media
tells us what reality is and how
susceptible human beings are to images
you know what i mean like seeing used to
be believing but now seeing isn't
believing anymore right but like you can
make people believe a lot of things by
showing them echo chambers is it kind of
predicting some of that a little bit to
a degree i mean the
the the thing about at least the movie
when i think about it uh there were some
things that it was definitely prescient
about um
and
and then there yeah it's a good word and
then there were others that don't care
for it you don't care for me saying
it's like i invented the word no i do
like it i didn't 100 kidding and it was
it missed the mark in other ways yeah i
mean any movie where you're dealing with
futuristic stuff you're going to be
wrong on some things right uh but uh
yeah no it's
and i haven't watched re-watched it in
years but it lives rent-free in my head
uh even if i just seen it the one time
when i was 12 i think it was 12. it
would live in my course burned into you
it was you were a clean white piece of
paper to a degree and this movie comes
in was that troubling for you
oddly
not really
um
but i think only because even at that 12
i'd already seen enough movies with
hard things to watch in them that my
parents knew about and had prepped me
for
so when i saw something i wasn't prepped
for on my own i was like oh no i mean
this is troubling like there is there is
a rape in that movie there's more than
one and it's
that is a tough thing to watch yes
that's all i remember yeah and i saw it
probably when i was like 14 or so yeah
and and so uh you know i definitely was
very uncomfortable and and felt bothered
by that but not in a way where
i was like oh i got to turn this off i
was more like
well
he's a monster let's see what happens to
him does he get his comeuppance does
does does he reform what what what
happens this character um and i couldn't
stop watching it right it was an ugly
story but you were invested in the story
yes yeah and that was the first movie
where you were like oh my god this movie
completely changed it changed the way i
thought about movies and storytelling
yeah and after that the floodgates
opened and i wanted to see everything
yeah yeah can i just tell you just
because i'm embarrassed that mine was
good will hunting okay
what's embarrassing we're having fun
no no and you don't have to be
embarrassed and here's why tell me um
i'm not super embarrassed but yours is
like cool it's like an art house film i
know that wasn't an academy award best
screenplay
and
and best supporting actor here it is
six seven seven yeah so i'm a senior in
high school okay
what is this this noise sucks it's a
weird noise
i'm glad we have cameras here because
people would not i hate what i'm doing
yeah it's this weird sort of that you're
celebrating i hate it
this is it this is the last time i do
that noise great uh but
i'm only saying this to see what it
makes you think of my friend john fonz
irelli and i we call them funds uh
fonzarelli would go we went and saw it
in woburn
and after it ends you know it ends with
will hunting which is stupid that his
name is wilhelm dumb it's really stupid
even maddie d has to be like if i could
change anything i changed that [__]
name
uh we just went for a drive and i really
vividly remember
the street light the street lamps going
by because i was in a different place
yeah like you kind of forget or
sometimes sometimes when i'm pitching a
movie i'll remind people like do you
remember what it was like being 16 17
and you watched a movie and it actually
like snapped you into into reality it
wasn't just an escape it was but when it
was over you were more in your body and
more in this time in this place than you
were before you watched it of the
potential of the magic of life all
absolutely right absolutely but not
enough people are talking about this i i
like that's the the that's what we mean
when we mean the magic of the movies
sure it's not the red vines
no it's the movie it's the story it's
the it's the
it's the leaving your reality to be
completely engrossed in this fictional
or possibly non-fictional story you're
watching yeah and it's the only thing
you're concerned with
and then the credits roll and it's a
crude snapping back into reality but
your brain wanted to keep that world
going that's why credits we watched a
movie last night and as soon as the
credits started in the corner it was
called like it started and the bar was
going real fast yeah i don't know what
app we were watching it on but it
started going like 10 seconds to like 30
blinks a minute or something some dumb
thing had nothing to do with what we
were watching and we were like we were
mad we're like [__]
you we just watched a movie give us five
seconds yeah to listen
it's perfect that it's black that it's
just subtle text you need that time
that
dead poet society is another one you're
devastated yes you don't want a little
icon in the corner being like 30 seconds
to too fresh for this island
get the [__] out of here
when did it become
you know
content consuming
coma like a food company basic cable bc
yeah because they were the first ones
that would um they'd show a movie with
commercials
and then instead of showing the credits
as the movie was intended that would go
into a small box yeah at lightning speed
yeah and then another box would come on
coming up next stick around for another
episode of the honeymooners yeah yeah
okay and you're helping me see and
before that you could watch this that's
what was great about premium cable hbo
cinemax they would show the movie start
to finish with as intended with credits
of course so anyway what i was saying is
don't ever be embarrassed about saying
you liked a movie or this is the movie i
saw that made me think x y and z because
you're talking about your favorites yeah
and when you're talking about favorites
anything goes no one can touch your
favorites no one gets your favorites if
you say oh um the movie i saw that made
me change everything was air bud 2.
and you're like i can receive right yeah
i i think that's the first one is an
airbud golden receiver the first time i
believe airbud
oh my gosh i don't know i don't know i
don't know airbud three i think is when
he swaps to basketball [__]
anyway i did don't make me go down that
rabbit hole my point is if everybody
retrieves if you and i are sitting here
and you were like can i tell you the
movie for me yeah cause again you said
airbud two i'd go tell me about it it's
like a religion or something right
because that's your favorite movie now
if i said to you pete what's the best
movie
yeah there's a correct answer to that
and it's the godfather but i didn't
that's not what we were talking about
that's not what we were talking about i
already referenced your favorite movie
you did
it's the best movie you think it's the
best movie i think it's the best movie
yeah yeah and with all due respect to
citizen kane and casablanca they don't
hold a candle the godfather
oh yeah i've seen i've seen all three of
these movies well
you're gonna hate this i've i've never
watched the godfather start to finish
you're gonna hate this i knew i knew
you're gonna hate this i knew you're
gonna hate those
here's our clickbait
no gallagher
gallagher no
come back okay here he is why
i'll tell you when i met valerie the
night we met
i told her we both uh said to each other
we had never seen the godfather
start to finish yeah and we vowed on the
night we met that we would never see the
godfather what a shitty vow why would
you do that to yourself i don't know
it's so good pete
it's not like have you seen why are you
quoting it to me if you've never seen it
because it's such a part of culture
that you don't even have to have seen it
i go to the bathroom sopranos finale i'm
going to speak to michael in italian
make an offer he can't refuse on the day
of my daughter's wedding
this guy's a real veto corleone you're
like a guy who like goes to work and
like overhears two co-workers talking
about
like uh a sporting event or something
that he definitely didn't watch and then
he goes out to drinks with his buddy and
he pretends he pretends that he watched
it sam yeah i'm gonna carve you a golden
uh no a people's choice award out of
soap because that's so right
i think the best movie is there will be
blood um deal with we'll deal with that
uh if that's what you think is the best
movie but i just wanted i'd be happy to
have that conversation yeah go ahead no
i i think what's your favorite my
favorite movie yeah clockwork orange
really we already talked about this no i
know who but i said what was the first
movie that opened you to the potential
also happens to be my favorite movie for
that reason listening to that part i'm
just kidding it was i forgot and i'm
embarrassed that's okay it's not like
the oxford cambridge thing that was
embarrassing
oxford cambridge you thought that you
didn't know they were two different
cities was that on another episode it
was i listened to your show pete
i'm embarrassed for you so
i hope so
if you're really pulling the curtain
back on the abc's of you
you should there should be some
embarrassing things in there that is not
true
i love how you are in your podcast
because you have been on a million i
have been on a million and they're
mostly horseshit and
this is such a real podcast
you're not sitting here with notes no
you know you googled and whatever stock
stuck and it seems like it's very little
but that's good
that's a good thing i knew it was
everybody loves hugo
[Laughter]
the lost episode look your wikipedia
page is thin what it's thin i haven't
looked at it in a while no i'm not
saying when it's bad thin yeah let's add
to it okay let's add this uh this is the
header okay um supernatural occurrences
i i i knew you guys asked me about this
and i'm i'm a bummer no you're not a
bummer here's the thing
if you believe in ghosts and you want to
see a ghost you go see a ghost yeah okay
if you believe in aliens and you want to
see a ufo i have no doubt in my mind you
are going to see a ufo really have i
seen ufo sure have i've been in plenty
of airplanes i've looked out the window
and seen stuff in the far far distance
that i went what in the [__] is that
that doesn't look like an airplane that
doesn't look like a balloon or a blimp
what the [__] could that thing
be i'm never gonna know and i will move
on with my life i'm pretty certain
whatever it is is either too far for me
to tell but probably man-made and that's
how i'm gonna go on with my day but you
know that it's like confirmed that
they're out there right uh it's not
confirmed that they're out there what
it's confirmed is that there have been
what i just described like air force
guys the air force is like we don't know
what happened we don't know what this is
yeah and here's what i say to that and i
mean i've read lots of it because it is
fascinating just to read about and like
to hear
not some knucklehead in the midwest but
right air force i read all that when
they dumped those documents yeah what
did these guys see how did they describe
it what got caught on video and i've
seen the videos and stuff they've
released and i'm like yeah i have no
explanation for what that is but here's
what i will say um the united states
government and like most other giant
superpowers they have different
divisions
in their military branch they do not
talk to each other or share information
right so if the nsa or the air force
or you know mi6 or whomever if they this
is working on some sort of thing they're
not gonna just be like uh listen fbi we
just wanted to give you guys a heads up
we're gonna be doing some weird
experiments at 70 000 feet uh it's not
your jurisdiction yeah they're not going
to tell anyone yeah they're just going
to do this yeah if you have a tic tac
that can make a right angle and because
most of the people seeing this stuff are
air force pilots and not commercial
airliners something tells me this stuff
is happening
way far away from where any commercial
airline would ever fly i.e the safest
place to try out this equipment if you
were a government looking for airspace
that doesn't have a whole lot of
action going on in it so yeah you go
crazy up north by the polls and you try
out your
80 billion dollar spy thing yeah and
some pilot sees it goes i don't know
what the hell that is i've never seen
anything move like it and then somewhere
in russia they go hey hey we got away
with it and that's that and it's good to
give it to russia well they
couldn't be us
well maybe it's us i don't know it could
have could have been us dude probably
was i'm like a little boy yeah it could
be hey it was us it was us i take it
back it's spider-man it was spider-man
right not russia spider-man it was
spider-man and doctor strangelove oh
i actually thought that wasn't a bummer
answer at all okay how about let's go
into the things that sammy does haven't
i thought that was great oh thanks he's
like what is this what is this okay
we're having a we're having a great
experience yeah uh
ever almost died oh yeah
many times uh
two that really stick out okay uh the
first i was 20 years old and i was
shooting a movie in mexico
and we were uh it was a beautiful place
where we're shooting the movie it was a
beach resort uh it's called broken
lizards club dread is the movie
is interested which we shot on this
gorgeous resort island in like southern
mexico and it was right there on the
water i remember and you were there too
no i just remember the movie i see my
favorite joke in that movie is when
farva whose name is uh
kevin heffernan kevin heffernan who's
great you did this podcast yep uh
he's you know he's a bigger guy but he
can chant and he becomes small
and so he becomes small so he can hide
and someone goes why don't you just do
that all the time and he goes this is a
fat joke
like
it's before is this a fat joke really
became
to me that's what made is this a fat
joke like a part of my life yeah but
like the most inappropriate time they're
they're afraid for their life and he's
like this is a fact i thought that was
so good
there's a lot of really great jokes in
that yeah yeah yeah and i'm glad that
it's found a really awesome devoted
audience over the 20 almost years now
it's been out but we were shooting that
movie there and we shot in the middle of
summer and uh we're so close to the
equator
and i've never been that close to the
equator and when you wander into the
ocean
um
and you're that close to the equator
it's like bath water warm wow the ocean
water it's a
stunningly strange experience to be in
ocean water that warm and it would stay
that warm pretty much all day
and you could swim out into the ocean at
night
wow and we often would we'd we'd wrap
the film the sun would go down we'd wrap
we'd all have dinner or something you
know the casting crew whatever we'd have
dinner at there was only one restaurant
there and then a handful of people like
oh we're gonna go for a dip then we'll
have a swim then we'll go to bed yeah
cause when you're thinking about a night
swim number one is it's gonna be too
cold that's why you don't sure number
two is it's scary as [__] yeah
dark water yeah and so i thought i would
join them the dark dark walk in the dark
dark water what kind of moon were we
looking at it was it was it cast a nice
moon you shot some moon there was there
was moon shimmer yeah there was oscar
isaac in the sky exactly
exactly sorry we're paid i'm paid a
hundred thousand dollars to mention the
show moon night wow
one night but but you called it
moonshadow
i'm correcting myself now it's moonlight
with oscar isaac
oscar winner
did he win an oscar
he is an oscar's nominee he's he's an
oscar yep
and he's a nominee for himself and he'll
definitely win at some point he's very
for moon night for moon knight because
that's a movie
stuff night stuff
go okay so
ah this riff this was okay it was fine
so
a riffing man it took me a while to work
up like it was a couple nights in and
i'd seen the people go out and they're
like 30 40 feet out off the shore a
whole bunch of them just hanging out
there and i remember thinking like ugh
i'm not really a strong swimmer and i'm
so nervous to like swim out and hang out
with that group of people clearly like
wading water 30 feet out like they all
must be in really good shape to like
hang out there and be having
conversations with each other and i
would love to be a part of that but i'm
not a good swimmer and so like on the
third night i was like out of hell with
it and so i
walk into the ocean you've been uh a
couple marks of dinner and maybe one
beer a couple mark simpsons
just one bigger just one beer one
service yeah i was a very lightweight uh
and i was gonna say still am but that's
not true that's a whole other story
you've worked on it the pandemic made me
an alcoholic not an alcoholic it gave me
the talent tolerance of an alcohol okay
all right in a good way actually a lot
of alcoholics don't have tolerances
because their liver says i know where
this is headed and they get drunk right
away wow
okay did not know thanks for the info
yeah so uh
i start waiting out and you know you're
walking you're walking not a tall man
and then there's that point where the
the sand just goes out from your feet
and now you're swimming
and i see
how far away they are
and i'm already swimming and fighting
the water i hate this and
i know
i get like a couple feet further and i'm
like nope i am not gonna make this
and then i turn around and start
swimming for the shore and then i get
caught
in the undertow and the wave i hate
every part of it it was not fun pete
and
sammy the machine yeah and i i'm an
asthmatic and i am not a good swimmer
and i am in terrible shape and i'm
running out of steam real fast and i
can't catch my breath and i'm fighting
and every time i think i'm about to get
back to the sand another wave hits me
and knocks me down and one of them was
so bad it knocked me and slammed me
against the bottom of the ocean which
had to be a mixed blessing because
you're like oh here's the bottom it was
i was like i can feel it but it's like
six feet beneath me yeah i'm five five
yeah yeah and uh
yeah and i you're halfway to a fake
thank you like i
this
is not good
and i
kind of start calling
i'm for help i'm now i'm with whatever
little breath i have left i'm like
and that's the best like
troopers it's the best i can muster with
the noise sounded like that no
and machine corner of my eye i see mike
weaver who is an actor uh in the movie
he's in a lot of the broken loser movies
and i see him swimming towards me and he
kind of sees me and i see him and i see
him and i think oh my god he's going to
have to save me
and i'm like
my and like i have nothing left
and i am fighting for my life
in water that i cannot handle and i see
him coming towards me and right when i
think like i'm about to have to say with
my last breaths above water like help me
mike
one of the waves just slams me forward
so hard it slams me against the bottom
but this time kind of pointing me
towards the shore and it bangs me and i
get up and on my very tiptoes
i'm able to get above the water line and
then i like
crawl to shore
and
i'd fought so hard for like what in my
mind felt like an hour is probably 40
seconds of course but i get to shore and
i had
nothing left i'm gasping for air and i
can't move and mike sees me and he did
not hear me screaming at her or trying
to scream at him because i know there
was very little sound coming for me and
he sees me like you're all right buddy
he's like wow you all right
and uh
yeah
it's so funny quickly we go from don't
die to don't make someone else
uncomfortable you're like immediately
like
i was like i don't want anyone to ever
know how clearly ill-equipped to swim
into the ocean i was um and i don't want
him to feel like i was just about to die
by the way unbeknownst to me until
almost the day we left because then i
was terrified to go back into the water
unbeknownst to me at least that area
where everyone was wading into the ocean
so it's like shore shore shore shore
dips
comes right back
uh it was a it was a crevasse all i had
to do was get beyond that like first
eight feet
and then the the floor comes right back
they were all just standing out there
i'm not
a pastor but i feel like there's a
sermon analogy there to be like
sometimes when you hit adversity you
actually have to go through
keep going because sam the machine
levine who died on the set of club dredd
he didn't know
he needed to keep going forward yeah the
only thing i can think is who they would
have recast my role with who's the guy
who snags your roles fred savage and it
it used to chain it was different for uh
years um
and before i uh say uh
some names i'm gonna give you two names
uh
you should i sh i would always think
like oh man those guys whatever i've
seen them in a million auditions and is
either gonna it was gonna be me or him
or this third guy and that was that
years ago somebody came up to me at an
audition
and saw him or not i don't know but he
saw me out and about somewhere and he
said you know you're the guy who takes
all my roles and i did not know who this
person was jude
and uh i'm only familiar with uh his uh
ex-wife
who's jude love's excellent sadie
sadie hawkins sadie hawkins
and that's the one where she asks you
today
i don't remember anyway uh
so he says oh you're the guy who takes
all my parts i was like what he goes i
saw you with this audition and this
audition in this audition and this one
and you booked all of those
and i felt terrible that i'd apparently
been in the waiting room with someone
who at least that many times and i
didn't recognize them and i was like
yeah i did book all those roles wow okay
that's crazy so i guess what goes around
comes around so whatever someone is to
me i am to someone else and i'm sure he
is to someone else
and that's how it is can't be sure about
that fair enough let's get him on the
come on in
alexa
call phil find all the phils that are
five five and call them yep uh finding
the one fill that's five five in
hollywood it's been a minute
but
uh shia labeouf and uh uh simon hellberg
laboufi yeah
you know his name in shia the beef
i do you know he was on freaks and geeks
i do he played he was a geek i believe
he was in one episode and the one with
the head yeah
when you got you just got married we're
gonna tell your second death story but
when you got married on your wedding
night
did you drop your silken robe
look at your bride and say
it's time for this geek to get freaky
were you in the room
you were weren't you
oh wow good to get further away from you
um
i i will tell you straight up that was
one of the longest most full days of our
lives getting married yeah and we knew
what happened this month uh uh at the
end of last month and wikipedia said me
well wikipedia is wrong it was april
citation needed
um in here and uh there you go that
citation uh
we knew ahead of time we were like
i'm laying the odds that we get freaky
on the night of the wedding for sexual
respect i'm actually in the odds at
least i've had two two weddings uh
because i'm divorced um both times and
val knows this sex after your wedding
get the [__] out of here
i'm just energy
yes
dancing eating it's a schmooze fest and
your body hurts everything i was in pain
no there was not a chance and we got
back to the hotel and there was roses on
the bed the hotel did it and we were
just like that's marriage and and when
people say that they usually mean it in
a bad way [__] you dating is when you're
like we did have sex but it was real
sort of like just kind of like two
jellyfish
and then there's you drowning
at least i got to see the jellyfish yeah
and here comes weaver he doesn't help
you
and then shia labeouf is over here
booking it he does drown
and everyone's like gives an applause
and he comes back it was performance art
he's that kind of guy he's that kind of
guy now yeah kind of brilliant right
look i i've given up trying to figure
out
some artists yeah and their and the way
their brains work because it's so
foreign from the way my brain works i
can't comprehend it and i'm like look
he's working on a different wavelength
and whatever he's doing is working for
him so but it seemed like labour had
some like negative labuzz and like
people were kind of like i don't know
about this labouf guy and then he was
like oh yeah i'm gonna eat 75 bananas in
a room while i'm crying and then we were
all like
and now yeah the boof is la back yeah i
guess i don't know
i don't know i mean i don't feel like
he's gone
i don't think he's gone he's he seems
active and you know we'll see him in
something he played a latino assassin
recently okay i missed that i'm pretty
sure he was latino did you see that
movie i did not he's playing like a was
that west side story two what's that
tori it's a prequel
called east
[Music]
theaters you're at the checkout and
there's the the vhs east side
it's wrapped in a way that you know it
was returned and re-wrapped
[Laughter]
this was a return and it's only 2.99
second death story or no you got married
uh we had jellyfish sex you were very
tired at the end of your wedding that's
true but you still managed to for the
geek to get freaky
we've had sex since then we have
consummated the marriage oh you didn't
have sex on your wedding night we did
not
can i just say good for you oh thanks
that's like the best sign
what i'm saying is yeah intimacy yeah
that i've been doing this bit about it
it's like i don't like dating i don't
want to be on stiff dinners trying to
impress somebody
if at the end of a 19-hour party
you're both in love enough to be like
let's sleep yeah
boom welcome welcome to the party we we
knew that that was
going to be the way that was going to
happen yeah yeah yeah
so there was no expectation great uh if
anything there was the expectation of
we're going to be so tired yeah we will
fall asleep before our heads hit the
pillow zeros expectations yeah um there
you go did you step on the glass i did
not ooh
can i be your mother for a second sure
fish shame
it was a shonda
a shonda rhimes what happened at this
um we thought about it i thought about
it no chairs no chairs no
yep no horror no chairs that was
i have no
yeah couldn't do it why i'm so
interested i'll tell you exactly why so
by the way yeah also
who cares like i'm not asking you to
defend yourself i'm just curious because
i'm so cultureless not really but i'm
just a little white bread okay that's
fine when i go to a jewish wedding and
there's the chairs and there's the glass
i'm a little uh
tradition envious okay i felt that way
about bar mitzvahs as well i was like
i'm 13. no one gives a [__] oh yeah no
that would have been right yeah you just
don't have the induction and some sort
of belonging right that the the other
faiths do it as well but judaism really
seems to nail so when i say why there's
no judgment i'm just i'm interested and
i'm happy to tell you uh so while i was
raised jewish
um and i was bar mitzvahed and
everything i have not been a practicing
uh member of the jewish faith
isn't that i'm not trying to
tease isn't that par for the course
i know a lot of jewish people that are
still gonna do a jewish wedding but are
like i'm not really oh maybe yeah i
don't know um i mean i've certainly been
to jewish weddings but i assume catholic
too or a lot of every faith that has the
language so my wife is not jewish okay
um
she was
raised
irish catholic i guess great that
doesn't sound great guess um great great
zero
that's not it we've really i don't know
anything about it it's definitely not
yeah i don't yeah yeah it's a whole
there's the communion i don't know so
the point is where is she from uh she's
from the boston area she's from good gas
lowell massachusetts good guess lowell
very good guest irish catholic yeah but
keep going i mean that part is not a
guess oh the lowell or the irish
catholic there's there's an irish
catholic heritage she is lewis okay go
ahead anyway so uh lowell yeah i haven't
thought about lowell in a while
dickie uh
uh eckland dickie eklund from the
fighter
oh my god um
it has nice parts too no i'm thinking
about
i was thinking about the plight of his
story it's sad but it's got a happy
ending that story
brutalizes me
well anyway it's going uh the pride of
lol the point is neither of us has been
particularly religious
so when we talked about the wedding
early on we were like
totally secular right yes yeah and so
for me she was more than willing to do
any sort of religious stuff and i with
her if it was important to her we should
have it yeah but
uh originally i thought all right i'll
do the glass thing and then the more i
thought about it we looked it up
and i was like cause i'm not gonna do it
if i don't know why i'm doing it i'm not
gonna do it well it's tradition
everybody does it but why
yeah and we looked it up and there's no
single straight answer
by the way go ahead i encourage you to
go what are some of them uh here's the
one that really stuck with me
um [__] glass
hate glass i've known this they own they
only want plastic that will never decay
yeah
it's got to poison the earth
we're an angry people
uh
here's my favorite reason marriages fail
because evil spirits
invade the marriage
and they're waiting when couples get
married when they form that bond that
union that's when they latch on to the
couple and then they sow their seeds and
their weight to destroy the marriage
but
if you break a glass
the noise scares the evil demons away
and then you'll have a happy marriage
because they didn't attach themselves
and i was like that's a little call me
now right now it's a little call me now
right there maybe yeah and that's very
sorry
i am not going to do that do not sound
go in there
so i was like all right if that's
if even one person who stepped on a
glass did it for that reason i'm not
doing it interesting so uh boy i'm
i'm surprised that it's that i thought
it was some beautiful metaphor there are
other reasons yeah it's like uh the word
swag
um
look up the word swag and you will find
a hundred different definitions
for swag for what it means it's an
acronym
it is yeah so the most the the one that
i grew up with was stolen without a gun
people now they ah i went to a movie
bringer i got a bunch of swags yeah
stuff we all get
there's a million reasons a million
definitions that people have assigned it
over the years i don't like stuff we all
get because the whole point of swag is
not everyone gets it
only the people that went to the
mission's been completely altered over
the years whenever it's an acronym i i
doubt it because okay is the same people
are like some president used to write
okay he thought it meant all complete
i'm like nobody who became the president
thought you all was spelled o-l-m but
the point is much like that if you
google why did jews break a glass at the
wedding you're going to get 50 answers
and one joke one about plastic obviously
because i put that on wikipedia
uh so uh yeah so we didn't do that and
the chairs that was something neither of
us wanted to be lifted in chairs
you are there's a size joke here but i i
would love to lift you in a chair um you
know when you did lift me it was nine
years ago i had to look it up uh we did
an episode of douglas movies it was you
me
tj and bert crisher uh-huh that's a loud
show oh
boy that's a loud and i don't remember
anything that led up to it i'm sure i
could find the episode in the archives
somebody check it out oh more than pick
me up i i ran and left okay into your
arms that's different i'm glad and you
picked me up like a bride you were
carrying across the threshold yes you
caught me and lifted me high into the
airplane wow and did it feel great it
was amazing i believe it and i found the
gif
uh there's a gift of weasel
uh the great lesser photographer uh uh
of who used to take pictures of all the
great ucb shows she took a video of it
and turned it into a gif and i found it
not long ago not only will i text it to
you when this episode posts we'll post
my first instagram post will be hey i'm
on finally you made it weird seven years
after that seven it's been so long and
uh and then
uh the next and you'll swipe and then
it'll be that gif
love need
i wish andre the giant was alive just so
he could pick me up and princess bride
too do you think andre the giants the
only person who could pick you up
yes
peter peter come here i want to pick you
up like sam levine oh can i pick you up
that's pretty good it's not bad
my impressions are not on
for some reason one day i can do it
and then today stop it
stop no i know it's getting worse
let's see where it goes
call me now
call
mr rana call me now
when's my call sheet
it was bad oh man yeah
um second death story sure uh skydiving
get the [__] out of it yeah i
i hate roller coasters i don't like
seeding control
i'm a bad person you mean you don't want
to be locked into a chair uh i don't
want to be locked into a chair what do
you mean by seating control uh
with my life if i'm in a car i prefer to
be the driver
i understand uh yeah so
if we're gonna die you want to be the
one i want to be the one who killed us
all i want to be the one who heard your
andre the giant impression oh my god so
unimpressed i turned this into one don't
turn into the traffic sounds too late i
am the dog pirate
no that's very good because he kind of
has like a horror when he yells well
sure he's got you had a mouthful of
uh and dip
both chips and
dip uh
yeah so i uh went skydiving for
uh john daly sweet john daly he i think
he turned
god how old was he hard to know he's
he's an ageless man
i think this might have been his 21st i
don't know he's
he's ageless now yeah we went skydiving
me him and a handful of other people uh
for his birthday and i did a tandem jump
as most people do for their first
skydive and i loved it
and it was um have you ever been never
will ever
everyone should skydive one time
some people only get to skydive one time
very few very very remarkably few people
skydive once and die remarkably few yeah
um
and so i loved it tell me everything and
you were strapped to the instructor yes
did he notice
that i've strapped to him he's a small
guy you got a fat joke
[Laughter]
i don't know why i'm punchy today i
really
wanted one small guy joke yeah is that
okay you just won why limit yourself
well look at us on this couch i look
like your son
[Laughter]
i did the reason i couldn't resist
is because the thought of you being
doesn't jump and didn't know it was a
tandem yeah yeah
like a like a pet who sneaks into your
car on your way to work god damn it
like that he didn't know something he
was halfway through the gym he's like
son of a [__]
and you were on the front right yeah
yeah yeah
were your feet done
i'm sorry you're my guest oh don't be
sorry don't be sorry that's what we're
here for i know that's what we're here
for all right um so anyway i did the job
and i loved it okay i went back a month
later i did another tandem job terrified
the first time uh a little scary because
you don't know what to expect yeah and
then the minute you realize what it is
what is it it's the greatest
sensation that absolutely cannot be
achieved on the ground
you are flying
you're flying you're flying down
but you're flying yeah you have your
feet are not on the ground you are
horizontal and you are moving about with
your arms
wow uh it's quite something so he didn't
pull it right away no no some they jump
and it pulls that would be a very bad
tandem skydive you want to jump and fly
yes and what are you going oh god oh god
or did you calm down you know you don't
want to open your mouth they don't teach
you this you don't want to open your
mouth when you're skydiving because uh a
things will fly in there and b
you're talking about wind going
approximately 130 miles an hour
your mouth will dry out faster
than you at a show
when you're bombing when you're bombing
that's it you know i've earned it yeah
i've been this ever since this the small
guy jokes i'm like we got to get petey
back nah it was about no i didn't know
no no no no it's enough no it didn't get
you but i'm joining you in the
initiative we're going to get petey
before this one's done okay that's right
well i'm sure i'll have another chance
yeah but my point is uh it will dry your
mouth out of course instantly yeah yeah
like ashton kutcher to vaginas when he
was put exactly
am i skydiving bottomless right now
maybe
so yeah that's that's the sensation that
you get there and you land and you're
euphoric for a long time it's wild yeah
oh yeah no you're i was definitely
euphoric for hours and uh and so i went
i did another tandem and after my second
tandem same day i know a month month
later and uh i took my dad and then um
i thought okay i enjoyed that too much
it's kind of all i think about i'm gonna
do it i'm gonna take the course i'm
gonna get trained and i'm gonna jump so
you were addicted
want i wanted to jump solo solo yeah i
wanted to jump chewy so keep going oh
boy
i like that you went with chewie
not chewbacca not too bad i went with
the the emoji less formal
but
i'm calling him chewy you put on pants
maybe i call you chewbacca
[Laughter]
no pants do you think he ever he never
has to wear put on formal wear
i mean how easy would that make your
life always new
he's like a bear i guess yeah
once a bear puts on jockeys you're like
now i'm thinking about how you're
topless yeah
anyway
uh
so i did it i took the course
and it was many hours in the in the
hangar with my great instructor uh and
we learned everything and uh and so i
felt very confident and very ready
um to do my first age this is under the
banner of times you almost died
i hate that this is the banner so they
were going up on the plane they slapped
my altimeter on me i got my shoot on my
instructor's with me he jumps with me
yeah you know holding on to me he's
going to t cruise your uh superman
but then once i i pull my rip cord
and i'm under canopy as they say
that i'm on my own
and that's that and i gotta with those
things yeah my risers yeah yeah and uh
so you're mad about yous
months i got my hunt and i got my riser
my lily candles more hunt more hugs my
retro kinds so i
uh i i jump and it's crazy because it's
a totally different sensation now
because my jump was
my free fall was so uncontrolled
because previously i'd been strapped to
the front and he was doing all the hard
work
my guy in back yeah this time it's all
on me i have to assume i'm not trying to
be like it's core straight that's like a
lot of like muscle like you're probably
exhausted yeah and and i was exhausting
and i did everything honestly all wrong
but like i i did enough i had to
demonstrate like a turn this way a turn
this way using my arms and making sure
my legs are in the right formation very
basic stuff while you're following her
this is true while you're falling so
i've already trained to do this yeah and
now you're jumping out and now i'm
jumping out and doing it and it was fine
and so
uh when you are free falling even if
you're right next to someone i mean your
faces are
right next to each other little kisses
you cannot hear
a single thing of course not the other
person is saying remember wind at 130
miles an hour yeah
racing past your ears so you communicate
with your instructor via hand signals
yep like excuse me and like scuba diving
exactly and i don't know why he made me
wear that tank it seemed like way too
much weight
so uh
the we were free falling and i we jumped
from 15 000 feet
and i am supposed to pull my rip cord at
4 500 feet my feet are sweaty which is
for the record a really high distance
above the ground the reason i'm supposed
to pull that to give you a frame of
reference like professional skydivers
will pull a thousand feet off the ground
800 feet off the ground t cruise fallout
sure we're looking at 25 feet above the
25 feet above the ground yeah that's too
crazy so um
uh
at 4 500 feet the idea is
if you pull your rip cord and you don't
have a clean opening you've got plenty
of time
to fix it or cut away and go to your
reserve yeah that's the whole reason you
literally have a knife to cut it uh no
it's it's built within the the shell
yeah which is what they call the the
pack that contains both your parachutes
uh there's there's a thing in there that
you have to physically you pull it and
it literally comes off and you let go
and that cuts your main chute away okay
and then your reserve is a different all
i'm thinking is what if you're it
doesn't and then you do that and you
realize you cut your back up shoot away
you cannot cut your uh reserve away i
like that there's no mechanism for that
very good so anyway
um
i uh i'm dying i'm freaking out i go and
i pull i know you're sitting here with
me yes i pull my rip cord and sure as
[__]
malfunction
on my very first solo jump it means i
did not have a clean opening my shoot
was partially open but not open all the
way a semi and a semi it was half staff
yeah it had seen maybe a boob side boob
could be a fat guy not sure half staff
twab so
uh
i'm looking up and here's part of the
training by the way is they put you in
the rig that put you in the harness
in this thing in your and my instructor
stands over me with these giant
photographs
over my head and each photograph is a
perfect photo of what a particular
malfunction looks like from that angle
so he holds that over your head while
you're in this harness who is taking
those photos oh malfunction
click
yep save it for the gram oh we lost so
many men taking this photo so many good
men and women
uh anyway so uh
i'm so basically the point is yeah
you're you're meant to look up and you
have to identify the malfunction and how
to fix it within a split second or they
won't let you jump like that's part of
the training
show but yes
and so he
like i look up
and i immediately identify what the
malfunction is
and i'm trying to fix it i'm try i'm
doing my best doing all the things i'm
supposed to do
and uh well actually i left out a giant
part of the story which was i'm
free-falling a giant
i'm free falling next to andre the giant
he falls by the way at the same rate as
i do would he yeah well terminal
velocity i don't know physics and i
don't know
32 feet per second squared until you
reach terminal velocity and if there's a
feather and a ball at the same time in a
vacuum yes they'll fall at the same rate
but with air no i'm kidding i think
andrew the giant probably would have
fallen faster than i would but not by
much just a little bit once you hit
terminal velocity it's all the same but
he would achieve it probably faster than
me
but then we maintain at the same speed
there you go
so um
i'm free falling with my instructor and
everything's fine i'm doing my elements
everything i'm supposed to do and i keep
checking my altimeter and i'm like all
right 8 000 feet we're good
seven thousand feet we're good and then
i'm like doing something and then like i
feel a hand on me and i look over and
it's my instructor giving me the pull
your rip cord
and like i feel him like grabbing at me
like he's gonna pull it for me and then
i glance down at my altimeter and i'm at
2500 feet
no like it went from like 7000 to 2500
in a second was there an issue with the
altimeter you just was
it stuck
it it held up on something and it just
went
[Music]
so you had one job one job altimeter so
i pulled the rip cord and now i'm free
falling by myself but i know i'm 2000
feet below where i should and now i'm
dealing with a malfunction and uh i'm
wearing a jumpsuit they make all the uh
poop suit and within the jumpsuit i am
actually wearing a walkie-talkie on a
string around my neck tucked in i mean
it's pressed up against me and that's
there so that a second instructor on the
ground
after i open my canopy can if i need he
can walk me through okay a little more
right all right a little more left to
help me with my landing okay um
but the problem was when i pulled i
didn't have a clean opening and i'm
still falling
pretty fast and the wind is rustling and
all i hear is
because of my flappy
not fully open yep uh main shoot now
this is gonna sound really shitty but
it's a giant pain in the ass when any
skydiver
cuts away and goes to their reserve
because then that
shell and that
shoot can't be used again like reserves
have to be inspected and certified when
they get packed but a regular shoot can
be inspected and packed by someone who
works at the drop zone the reserves have
to be inspected by someone who works for
like the united states parachute okay
association or whatever and um
so they don't they really
want you to learn how to fix your
malfunction and not panic and cut away
yep and so i remember that and i'm
trying but on one hand
sammy the machine levine and on the
other hand you have a slight
inconvenience on the safe safe ground
you know so i'm trying really hard to
fix it and at this point i no longer
trust my altimeter and it's my first
solo jump i've done do tandems and so
i've got a fair idea at that point about
like just looking at the horizon and
trying to guess how far above the ground
you are
but i i said to myself like i i hadn't
really panicked i panicked a little but
i only started to panic when i realized
my altimeter isn't working this isn't
working i know they don't want me to cut
away but god damn it all right i'm gonna
try
one last time to fix this malfunction
yes and if i don't i'm cutting away
because when you cut away you go back
into free fall until you open your
reserve as if things happen
i'm like if i cut away and i go back
into free fall i might have be a hundred
feet off the ground before i get my
reserve open yeah so that is also in my
brain
and uh so i try one last time i give it
absolutely everything i have what is the
technique to fix it i have to
full flare as hard as i can pull both my
risers
full lego full guy from jerry full guy
fieri full flavor tone
and so uh i did it
i did it i gave it everything i had like
i was swimming for my life in the
pacific ocean off mexico yeah everything
i have and then it goes
and now i've got it now i'm fully under
canopy fully uh
engorged canopy and i immediately start
falling a lot slower
and i look at maltimeter which again i
don't trust and now i am i don't know
800 feet off the ground which is pretty
low
it sounds high
but if you've never been under canopy
before sammy i i'm hoping for uh above 4
000. there you go
so
uh only then am i now able to hear the
guy on the walkie and all right all
right maybe australia all right made me
feel pulling anything and then he guides
me and i land on this nice sand thing
and then
they're running over when you land you
have to give the thumbs up that you
didn't break your leg or anything when
you're landing and i give the thumbs up
and i'm like out of breath because i've
been fighting my parachute the whole way
down and they're running over and
the uh australian guy this is what he
says to me
mate couldn't she hear me on the walkie
i was like what he's like
you were at 1500 feet you had no air in
you rear rises i was telling you to cut
away
oh no
they wanted you to dig ditch it yeah
oh god
i was like oh so i just cheated death
high fives all around let's do it so
they did
not making it about me at all one time i
scuba dove ran out of air and the
instructor when we got to shore acted
like nothing had happened she was sort
of embarrassed did they sort of go like
oh we had a deli of a pickle today mike
no he was uh upset with me yeah because
he was like because i think frankly if i
died splatty the machine
he would have been in some trouble i'm
in trouble now
and i don't just mean repacking this at
the plant oh they're gonna send me back
to the colony i gotta get all the
criminals wait that's where i'm from
australia that's how it started pick
this guy up with a laserdisc he's as
flat as a pizza
that's a 90-minute back right there oh
it was good
it was a good one sammy yep did you do
it again after that i did
you are a freaky [__] jumped 11 more
times after that 11. i got halfway
decent
uh at being a solo skydiver i was very
confident and i felt like i could handle
just about any malfunction that was
thrown at me saved for like bag lock
which is when nothing works and you're
like well gonna die um but that's bad
wildly rare i'm going to say it for the
people skydiving
bag lock bag lock yeah
um anyway
if you do have a big look can you go
ahead and grab your instructor
i was seeing a hail mary for you oh no
but you're not catholic and he lit a
candle
and stepped on the glass yeah so um
the reason i stopped after my 11th solo
jump was i
had a really rough landing
and i
had already i've i don't have great
knees and i hurt my knees so bad it
didn't break i didn't tear anything
but after this rough landing i was
limping around
for a month
letting it heal
and i had this thought where i was like
how do i explain to my agent
oh i would love to take that role that
amazing once in a lifetime role that was
just offered to me yeah but i can't
because i can't walk right now yeah
because of a skydiving accident yeah
yeah
like i work in an office
and i can do that and if i had a broken
leg it's fine it's an inconvenience but
it's fine right but so i was like also
and i've almost died once so
if i do it from here on out i'll just do
tandems i'm either impressed or
terrified that you kept doing it did you
after the bad one did you take a break
or do you no i came back like three
weeks later three weeks later well i
mean it was a near-death experience but
it didn't feel like i was about to die
like the ocean thing i thought i was
going to die in the ocean yeah with this
happened i was a little panicky
but honestly like
i had just taken the course
the info had never been fresher in my
brain and i had the over overconfidence
if someone's like nope they showed me
what to do i know what this malfunction
is yeah
and it wasn't
it was just a matter of okay one more
time then i cut away and it is what it
is
uh
yeah i love that the cutaway they're
like don't lose your deposit mate
[Laughter]
that's 75
we got to get
you know
jennifer from the
parachute organization she's got to come
out here you know you don't want to try
you don't want to have trouble jennifer
it's a sunday mike come on
i saw reese derby last night and i just
immediately went up to him and i was
like i met in wisconsin and i was like
pete the boat has drifted too far from
the shore oh it's just it's yeah it's
become that yeah he's so talented i love
him i don't care for him great um
just kidding rhys you're great i said
congrats on the show and he went yeah
it's just great to be back in the game
again and i thought that was the
funniest way to respond to congrats on
the show it's great to be back in the
game again that's like i love that
response
uh and he is hilarious i was jk yeah um
okay so we're at the end and he had a
secular wedding and we know that you're
non-religious non-religious zero
religion what it um what do you any
framework for the for the phenomenon of
existence
uh we are not having children
say what you heard me no i know
but how is that i said any framework for
the phenomenon of existence like a like
a belief structure and you said we're
not having trouble oh i thought you
meant the phenomenon of existence like
bringing a new life no no but i'm
interested no kids no no kids done done
uh
there's a lot of reasons not to have
kids one world is so sad or whatever uh
yes or is it more like we want to eat
nachos we want to eat nachos in the sad
world by ourselves
it's it's everything it's so many
different things yeah i hear you uh and
uh we are selfish people who would
rather spend the money on ourselves and
enjoy our 40s and 50s and 60s and
70s
probably not for me
heart problems
no i'm gonna skydive again in my late
60s and you know it'll be so complicated
when you land it sounds like someone's
opening a bag of sun chips you know how
loud those bags are
do you remember the sunship bags that
were biodegradable that's the one i mean
that's the one you're talking about the
ones they just continued because they
were too noisy it was the loudest bag in
the world that's you when you land in
your 60s but that's but that's
consumerism
huh that's consumerism hey this bag is
great it gives back to mother earth it
makes noise yeah all right kill the
program
buddy i think about that all the time
yep don't forget yep
would cut a lot of corners if it means
making i i don't mean we i mean all
corporations would cut a lot of corners
and keep looking for the the scientific
lab that will say that the mcrib sauce
is healthy
if it means making 30 more dollars
annually um framework for existence
uh we're all here for a good time not a
long time
huh i don't know that's the first time
no it's the first time you've ever said
it but it's the second time he made this
feel like a dose of keys commercial
you're a man you're a man of leisure and
we're not here for a long time we're
here for a good time there you go here's
how uh i feel about it
i've read
i was fascinated by theology when i was
a teenager and i read quite a bit about
it and all the basis is the basis of the
major religious
religious you're becoming me yep the
religion i'm trying i'm trying to i'm
broadcasting this
voice times
um
uh uh
so
it's all fascinating and here's the
bottom line
much in the same way
that
uh
no one can prove
there is 100 of god i know there's a
hundred percent of god there's a whole
plan there's a whole thing
on that end and then on the other end it
is foolish for a non-believer an atheist
if you will i am a hundred percent there
is nothing as a nope
either one of those polars you can be
99.9 yeah you can't be a hundred you can
feel
like it's a hundred but realistically
that can only be nine nine nine
that's where i am with the with my end
with the non
but in that
point yeah one yeah
i'm fine with everything else
anyone can believe do whatever they want
i could be wrong we could all be wrong
so god bless whatever makes you happy
excuse me fake god bless uh gosh bless
gosh bless oh damn it
jesus
jonah the whale nope uh chris said steve
jobs
whale
so my point is
i don't know
and
but my what i'm comfortable where i'm
comfortable is that end and tandem
skydiving and tandem skydiving uh no i
hear you well that's what i you probably
because you listen to the show you
probably heard me say this a million
times my it's weird to have a favorite
atheist but i am very similar to ben
gillette and his whole thing is we don't
know and he really taught me uh because
a lot of not a lot but some atheists are
the 100 percent no way and he's like
look i could be wrong i believe in
infinite potential infinite
possibilities i'm just saying the
evidence suggests that there isn't one
and and i i really appreciate that and
that's what i'm hearing here so if you'd
like me to compliment your worldview
here i am thank you i'm not i was not
fishing no no i didn't think you were
official but i didn't want you to think
that uh
sometimes by validating someone's
beliefs it can be condescending i didn't
mean it that way oh okay well thank you
yeah yeah as long as you weren't taking
it that way i did okay i'm leaving
so dead over
dead dead over yeah yeah you go back to
the earth which in and of itself i think
is pretty impressive
the the recycling of it all yeah of the
matter one day every cell that it makes
me up right now will be part of the
earth again and contributing to new life
and also every
atom and cell every cell that you are
is reborn every seven years and all this
stuff i love that
i'm sure you've heard that that image
the boat you inherit your father's boat
and then you replace the hull and you
replace the floors and after 10 years
you've replaced everything but you still
call it your father's boat yep that's us
there you go it's insane yeah it's just
really the difference the difference
between spirituality and materialism
which is what i hear you you know
completely understand
it's like which came first spirituality
says consciousness manifested matter
and the material says matter
developed consciousness to preserve
itself
just to join you in the delicious soup
you're serving please buddy
we are two bonobos
jumping out of planes what's that they
make halfway decent shirts bonobos is
that a company it's a shirt company i
own a couple yeah you own a couple yeah
bonobos.com sammy the machine levine
if you go and if they they're like hey
if there's a thing where it's like any
comments when you place your order just
let me know i sent you sammy sent i have
nothing set up with those people when
you write your name sammy 3ms
i don't ever write sammy
um
dangling participle
what is it we left one hit it
remembered a podcast i was a sick kid
and i spent a lot of time in the
hospital and at home and that's where i
started watching movies like it was my
life's work like fred rogers there you
go third once i
knew what i wanted to do with my life i
can't believe you remembered of course
once you should come every episode
once i knew what i wanted to do with my
life uh which was be in acting and
whatever and make movies and shows and
all that then i was like well this is
what i want to do i owe it to myself if
i want to be a pharmacist it's my job to
know all about every drug so i started
soaking that's why i take them there you
go that's i started soaking in every
movie movies i was like i don't care
well i have to watch it anyway
and so i would i've watched so many
movies and my love for cinema knows no
end so that's the quick wrap-up of that
what's a movie that no one else likes
that you love
free jack
free jack sure it's i mean it's not a
good movie isn't it oh it's emilio
estevez movie from the 90s emilio
estevez renee russo anthony hopkins mick
jagger
[Laughter]
faison love
uh
it's
ridiculous
a [__]
ridiculous do the preview for it i'm not
saying you have to do it but do the
preview for new jack for those of us who
don't know anything about it
alex furlong was a race driver
he's doing it
headed for the biggest race of his
career until
no
he died or did he oh
he's awake and it's 18 years later so
many movies in the 90s
and not only does he have a new chance
at life he's also got a run for his own
it's free jack
and i
we were under a full canopy on that riff
that was beautiful thanks man but he
dies and what it is
so he dies in an auto racing accident
yeah but in the so that's 1991 in that
scene
and in the future 2009
the future yeah
yeah you mean they have technology no
that's 13 years ago they have technology
where they can
snatch you
out of your
time zone your time line yeah at any
point they want and so
in that future
um
the the world the pollution is terrible
and so there's no healthy people so when
rich people are going to die they can't
just grab some body
from that time to put their
consciousness into to keep living
forever they snatch a healthy body from
the past so it's not just one crazy
conceit that you can transplant your
consciousness it's two it's i can
transplant it but only someone from the
past there's a couple of big ones yeah
it's based on a book called immortality
inc and it's also written by a narrator
in newspeak
i think robert sheckley wrote the novel
and i think dan gilroy adapted the
screenplay and it that out um only
because
actually we're we're doing okay for time
sometimes you go two three hours and
look i'm not some giant megastar
sammy the machine but
if we're having funsies and you don't
have anywhere else to be i cleared my
whole day for this oh my once
we're not rolling by anymore by the way
i'm not leaving
[Laughter]
you me val katie if she wants to hang
around
leela yep everybody i don't want to
forget anyone in this yeah in this house
and there's a weird gnome man that lives
in the floorboards i live in the
floorboards nah very nice thank you for
making me feel better i did have a baby
carrier joke but we don't need it no
okay listen yeah tell me a tarantino oh
i got a couple goodies i love him um did
you hear him go because we love making
movies of course i heard him do it i
heard him do it a thousand times on our
set so the reason that comes up is
you're doing a take let's say we're
we're shooting a take of it takes of a
scene and it's hard whatever you're
shooting is really hard it's complicated
there's a lot of dialogue maybe someone
has to do a stunt in it or whatever and
you do it and he sometimes will do a lot
of takes and so you're on take 14
and you know you've got it and you do a
take and he says cut cut that was
brilliant that was it that was the take
but we're gonna do it one more time and
why
and then everyone on set in unison says
because we love making movies
and it's
see that to me is
when you sit down to write something
great yeah you have a better chance of
writing something great when you remind
yourself that you love something you
have a better chance of enjoying the
experience being in the moment staying
with it do you think that's what it is
uh it's a lot of that but like i think
he has never
allowed himself to forget his childlike
exuberance
uh of his love of cinema and that he
gets to do
at the highest level he gets to do the
thing that makes him happiest yep in
life he gets the golden ticket and he
doesn't want to ever
make it feel like a job or an obligation
yeah like i get treated
whatever is in my head on a piece of
paper and then i get a blank [__]
check
to make whatever version of it i see fit
i'm a happy
as a child in a candy store every day
i'm on set yeah yeah and he wants to say
you only want to make 10 movies because
in his opinion and i'm
i learned of this his intent to stop
making after 10 movies i was having
dinner with him and bj novak
just the three of us it was a lovely
evening and somehow that came up and
he's like no i'm going to turn 60. i'm
going to make my 10th movie and i'm done
we were like whoa that is really
and we were both
come on you've got no i'm just that the
other and here's what he did say and he
he sort of said this in the years since
but i've never heard him really say it
but i i know he said it to us he said
after that i will become a man of
letters
and i was like i
didn't go to college what does that mean
and he was like he's just going to write
letters he's i'm going to write a c
and then an x you're going to become the
character maybe maybe some stuff with an
uml
uh and so it's a very
focus on writing more than directing
writing movies writing books books he's
he's the novelization of uh uh once upon
a time in hollywood i don't know if you
read that he wrote it already oh years
ago it was it's terrific it's the story
you know but there's so much more cause
it's a book
he wrote it of course he wrote it me no
no this oh
petey wow you gotta read it is it like
deleted scenes
it's the only movie i have on my phone
then because i can always watch read the
book i will it's very good um so he's
gonna write more books i think he's
gonna write some plays
uh he may write like a mini series that
maybe he'll produce but at this point i
am now believing him that he's got one
more movie in him and his timeline's
close i think he's around 60 but uh yeah
i think we got one more left and that's
how he wants to do it and look he's been
doing like we're full circle this is the
retirement thing yeah he's been doing
the thing that he wants to do for so
many years of his life now
he's
you know it's troubling because he'll
he'll say things like when he finishes a
movie like oh when i want to do uh the
vega brothers oh and i want to do kill
bill volume 3 and oh i want to do the
prequel doing glorious bastards and none
of these things ever happen at least not
as films so it is my belief that after
he stops making films he will write the
book versions
of these things he will publish the vega
brothers he will publish kill bill
volume three
unless that turns out to be his tenth
film and then everyone will read it and
be like
it should be a pretty good movie pretty
good movie wouldn't be a pretty good
movie well maybe he'll put stuff in
there where he's like these can be
adapted into movies after i'm dead
that wouldn't strike me as something
that he would shy away from so tell me
another
okay here's um
people often ask me what is he like as a
director and here is the best example of
that that i can give and apologies to
other people who've heard me talk about
this on other podcasts uh but it's too
good a story and if you've heard it get
ready to hear it again
so um in the
uh film one of the first times we really
see the bastards in action is when donny
donowicz comes out with the bats yeah
and you know
[__] fenway [__] pack
teddy [__] ball game yeah uh yeah so
uh uh brad pitt what is this yeah my
buddy
he loves us yeah he does this in a lot
of movies yeah the thumb over the
shoulder the shoulder
he wants that yeah yeah i always thought
he was doing like a brando thing with
aldo rain
i never asked him about it specifically
the only thing we ever talked about in
terms of performance we talked about
accents
because he was he's giving he was doing
a little twang he did in another movie
too yeah i'm gonna do this queen yeah
it's the voice i'm gonna do a little bit
who got my throat it's never established
all right you want to know the answer um
it wasn't cut
the back story for this skull oh it was
a hang it was a hanging
his he he said i'm a mountain man
director from you know jim bridger so
he's from appalachia mississippi
somewhere i'm from abella and the back
story there is some years earlier in his
younger life he saw a couple of
black men
being mistreated basically they were
going to try to get lynched by some you
know
racists in the area and he stepped in oh
and saved their lives and in the process
they hung him not enough to kill him
just enough to teach him a lesson
oh wow and that's how he got the scar on
his neck oh wow there you go breaking
news that would be in the book uh
probably uh so
anyways
it's us in that ditch
uh where you know we've got the nazi
prisoners and we're trying to get
information out of them and so that was
the first thing we really shot like the
first big thing we shot
and
so it's day one of that we were there
for i think six or seven days
it's a big scene there's a lot to shoot
a lot to cover yeah he takes his time
because he can
so we're there and i don't know if you
remember my portion of that scene yes
i'm laughing yeah and uh you know that's
when uh he says uh you know all right uh
uh uh what's my character's name
hershberg i'm gonna send over that uh
that sergeant that crowd sergeant and
you know i mean that means and so he
goes over and then he gets you know
beaten to death you know that portion of
the scene
as it happens
uh this scene was a bit larger than that
initially i had quite a bit of back and
forth you guys steve jobs i got steve
job like i said it's happened to me
plenty yeah so i'm it's part of the job
yeah i don't take it personally part of
the job part of the job so
we had a little bit of back and forth
there so he says you know harrisburg
sent over that crowd sergeant and so as
scripted and as shot
uh you know i'm holding my rifle the
guy's on his knees wonderful actor
richard sammel is the actor's name who
played uh sergeant uh uh oh no
oh this is it's too early for me it's
rachman sergeant rachman so um he's uh i
don't want to point out we started at 10
a.m i don't know what time it is and sam
is
40 years old and keeps complaining i
katie and i had a good laugh about how
you were like 10 a.m
i got three hours sleep last night
that's true what it's i can't i have to
come back to the bastard story i got a
terrorist sleep last night asked me why
do you only get three hours
you're not going to believe the answer
to this question why because my wife and
i
were binging downton abbey
wow
and we were like two episodes away from
finishing the sixth season
and it was like two in the morning i was
like god damn it
fine let's finish it i'm not going to
bed i'll be thinking about it all night
let's do it wow and the last one is like
two hours long
and we did it we stayed up and it was
like
[__] 4 45. this is why you were
drinking a red bull when you came to the
dinner get up and do pete holmes and
he's gonna but you could have pushed him
i matched your energy you sure did you
brought the good energy
and you declined the free magic mind
beverage oh no i'm gonna use that in the
car i'm freebie it'll get you it's going
to be free
so uh anyway back to bastards uh the
great guy playing the sergeant sergeant
rachman richard sammel
so
he says al lorenzo
herzberg send that crowd sergeant over
and so here's as scripted
i say
that means you cupcake
and he does not respond and then
i am supposed to
bang him in the back with the butt of my
rifle and then i say when the lieutenant
says move you move
and he still doesn't he still doesn't
react to that and then i am to grab him
by his hair
yank him up to his feet
and he turns around at me and looks at
me and we have a little bit of a stare
down
and then i you know i was like what you
know and when lieutenant's talking you
get over there and then he you know
turns around and he walks over and then
you know the rest of the scene he sits
down he has to talk with aldo donowicz
comes out beats you interesting i wonder
if it was another moment because all the
hate that we have or the desire for to
watch this guy get hit yeah the baseball
yeah bat which is a lot yeah
i'll admit that when i was watching that
scene it was it was difficult i know
he's a nazi yeah in a movie still i'm
i'm kind of like ah like seeing somebody
bound and killed yeah is never fun no i
i i always get nervous when i talk this
way i'm just saying as a moviegoer
and also nazi yes i get it yeah
i wonder if your part
was to help us remember this guy's a
[__] piece of [__] yeah you know what
i mean and the look he's gonna give you
is like disgust and he's an [__] and
he
[__] re all that yeah
the movie was like five hours so yeah he
shoots everything yeah and then figures
it out in the edit yeah um so
we go to do that portion of the scene
for the first time and he's got the
camera up at the top looking down it's
kind of a medium wide
and he's all the way up there with the
camera he doesn't have a video village
he always stands by the camera and
either watches in a little viewfinder on
the side of the camera or he watches the
actors because he trusts bob richardson
his dp to get the shot right so
we do the first take of that
and he's ah cut cut cut and because he's
all the way up there it takes him like
two minutes to run over where the the
ladder is climb all the way down there
come over to talk to his actors and brad
pitt's next to you going like look at
this dumb [__]
brad pitt's like
i think moneyball will be my next movie
was it yeah it sure was at least the
next movie he shot he takes out the book
[Laughter]
michael lewis you've done it again so uh
you got a lot of names he runs he runs
down and he comes over to me and he
pulls me away from all the other actors
here's the thing here's the thing okay
um
you're some [__] american jewish kid
this guy
is a [__] sergeant in the nazi army
okay
he would kill you with his bare [__]
hands
if he could
and the only thing stopping him from
doing that is the fact that you're
holding the rifle he's not
and there are 12 other rifles around him
he knows one wrong move and he's gonna
get blasted to hell that's the only
thing stopping him from [__] killing
you
and you know that you want him to make a
move you want an excuse
to tell your [__] lieutenant what
could i do lieutenant he was antagon he
came at me i put a hole through his
chest you're looking for the excuse man
i need to feel the fire i need to feel
the want from you
that you want this guy to make a move so
you can put a hole in his neck and i was
like
done
and then
he goes over to richard and pulls him
aside
and i do not know what they're saying
and then the last thing he says right
before he goes back i was like okay
nobody talk to each other stay in the
moment and then he runs back up to the
stair runs over the thing okay i had
action
and we go to do this scene a second time
and now uh
hershberg send that crowd sergeant over
and uh that means you cupcake and now
i'm [__] in it now it's fire and i
bang him so hard i know i kind of hurt
him when i bang him with the butt of the
rifle sergeant said he lights in and
says you move you move and i yank him up
to his feet and he turns around he's
staring at me and i got my rifle
and it's a moment and it's going on way
longer than it did last time and i'm
looking at him and he's looking at me
like what what and i start poking them
in the chest
with the butt or with the with the front
of the other rifle he's looking at me
and it's a moment and it goes on so long
and finally stops
fixes his
jacket turns and walks away and then
they get another little piece and then
the scene ends
god
brilliant brilliant brilliant shut out
again do that again we're gonna go again
and then he comes over and i say richard
what did he tell you
and he said oh
um
he told me that when i turn around
and you point the gun at me
that if i didn't believe that you'd
really shoot me
that i should try to grab the gun away
from you
and then that would be the new scene and
he'd rewrite it
[Laughter]
and then that would be the new scene
and i'd rewrite it in the woods in the
woods in the middle of nowhere in
germany we need ten minutes
yep
because he needed something authentic
wow and if we couldn't get to the
authentic thing he wanted he'd make him
find the authentic thing we could do and
he'd make that the scene and what he
wanted and what do you want
well we'll edit that story out i i think
you should i didn't like it i think you
should edit that i don't like you oh
well the feeling is mutual
you're too tall
uh you know when i listen to your
podcast and i listen to it all the time
like i've said for many many many years
big fan uh
when you laugh
it is so dudly more arthur-esque dudley
moore arthur arthur yeah
yeah because you you haven't really done
it much today but uh as recent as i
would have liked to
that's on me
that's on me as recent as chris brownell
you do that
and i'm so bummed you didn't do it today
i was ready to call you up
you do that arthur is one of the movies
i watched as a youngin and i think it
was one of the first times i saw my
dad's cognitive dissonance
meaning the movie was making him laugh
and then he felt the need to be my
father and be like it's sad when
somebody drinks like that
and i'm like did he say that with
with a drink you know it's
really quite sad no
i've never done my dad with like a
cartoony drunk slur yeah let me try
is your dad andre the giant
very similar voice
alpha is a very sad man
i prefer the
remake i'm just kidding
it felt mean i didn't mean it to be mean
but nobody prefers
the sequel there we go there's lots of
ways
arthur on the rock that's the sequel
well sammy the machine i do have
somewhere to be on forge
look parnell went too you've gone too i
kid i kid plus you have a nap to take uh
you have a nap now i'm gonna push
through you are yeah that's the way to
do it yeah it's all always about
caffeinate
oh i said it in front of you what a
caffeinated you're going to tolerate
give it a shake
but it says take alongside your morning
caffeine well because it has adaptogens
that ease it also says best serve
chilled and it's been sitting here well
that's not my fault what do you want me
to
record the podcast in the fridge yeah
on the off chance the guest doesn't
drink the magic mine that i tossed him
uh
okay look this is great you know the
question's coming yep
can you tell me
the hardest time
which is not the correct way to say it
the hardest time hardest time you've
laughed that's how we ask it i know
um
and
i have uh laughed very hard many many
times in my life
but the one time i remember laughing to
tears there's a small story and then
i'll explain the rest of it uh so
we didn't cover any of this and
seriously i mean this from the bottom of
my heart thank you yeah for not making
me go over my life story again
i've yeah i've done it on so many we
didn't do it i didn't ask you one freaky
one freaky geeky there was jiro freaking
zero if you want to hear that go to any
you want to hear us talk about red
balloons marshmallows
come here so um
i was a stand-up comedian when i was bar
mitzvahs yes bar mitzvahs and some
batman and some banai mitzvahs is the
plural when i banai but not mitzvahs
there you go i had a tumor it was a
banai oh mitzvah
hmm and then they asked the two people
jewish
and it was that was that holiday so the
the um what's the okay
i started going to the friars club the
new york virus club when i was 16 years
old uh my my my comedy stand-up comedy
uh godfathers uh elon gold and jeffrey
ross
um were
instrumental in me getting stage time
developing an act and all that and then
they brought me into the friars club
and there are no teenagers hanging out
in the friars club for good reason this
is the mid-90s and i'm in there and you
know it's dick capri freddie roman alan
king
uh they're holding court there every day
and i get in there
and i'm blown away like these are old
porsche belt comics
and they're just hanging out having a
drink telling stories i love comedy i
love jokes and the part of the story
that bums me out is i can't remember
which of these altacockers told the joke
i'll take cockroaches that's a great
word you should have it's a yiddish
old man
yeah uh
very old so uh i don't remember which of
them told the joke
but i remember the joke
and they told the joke and i laughed so
hard i'm crying at the table and then
all the other
these old comics are at the table geez
same thing you've never heard a joke
before i couldn't get it together i'm
laughing so hard you're in the water at
club dread basically yes but it's
laughter but it's laughter and i can't
breathe because i'm laughing so hard it
was just something about this sex it's a
street joke street joke it's a street
joke he just told a street joke one of
the comics told a street joke and it
made me laugh so hard and if when i'm in
a bad mood
when things are not going my way
i will tell this joke
out loud to myself wait you know the
joke oh of course i know the joke oh i
thought this whole time you didn't know
no i will i will i will tell the joke to
no one to myself in the car and it
automatically puts me in a bedroom you
tell me the joke of course i will tell
you the joke now before i do uh my dear
friend kevin pollock he tells this joke
and i love that he tells this joke he
doesn't tell quite the same version that
i know but i didn't want him to hear me
on this podcast and be like he's
stealing my joke i love the joke i love
the way kevin tells it this is the way i
heard it this is the way i tell it to
myself
um and here is the joke it is a little
uh uh you know
mean but so be it so uh
guys at a bar and uh it's getting it's
getting late and he needs to get laid
and you know it's closing time he's
looking around all the all the good
options are there and the only lady he
you know gets any interest from is old
kind of heavy
and he's well something's better than
nothing all right so he
takes her and go back to his place
thanks sir takes her home you know she's
happy to go with him and sure and and
and so you know he's trying to get her
warmed up so he starts going down on her
and uh you know she's older and and
heavier and you know he's going to town
really trying to get her warmed up and
he falls in
and you know and he's in there and
and he's you know kind of panicky and
he's he's feeling around and he's just
trying to find his way out and all of a
sudden he feels another arm hey av
oh my god there's another guy in here he
says this is crazy i i don't know what
happened i was going down and i fell in
how long have you been here i guess i've
been here a while it's a son of a [__]
well you know let's let's let's work
together let's let's let's try to find
our way out the guy says to hell with
that help me find my car keys we'll
drive out
oh my god
so many things are going through my mind
one of them
is how that joke was told in the 90s
like
you know what i mean
you told the 20 22
you know it's amazing that you were even
able to tell the joke
but the way that that joke was told in
the 90s
was probably a disaster sure it was a
modern day it was an aristocrat it was
an aristocrat i'm i'm you're being given
the queen
the queef
i'm giving the queen for the clean yeah
help me find my car keys we'll drive out
is very funny it's
[__] i sometimes i just have to say
the punchline
help me find my car hell with that help
me find my car keys i hope we're in a
dire situation one day
like club dread what is this a fat joke
and we're hiding
in a closet
and i'm just like
help me find my car keys we'll drive out
and you laugh you go and it and uh yeah
that's that's
a hilarious inappropriate time to make a
joke
in a movie like club dead sort of the
problem is i almost don't tell my
friends that because if somebody else
says if someone says
if we're at the altar
glassless yeah help me find my car keys
look right now that will get me and your
wife is to be is coming up and you just
laugh in her face i start laughing i
have to excuse myself leave the room i
come back tears streaming down my face
love it yep ate it there you go sorry i
didn't laugh like arthur that's okay
what a great answer i thought that whole
time by the way you didn't know the joke
because as a fan of the show you'll know
oftentimes people are like i don't
remember what it was which is fine yeah
and they don't have to but you knew what
it was uh help me find my car keys the
problem is since the very first time i
heard you ask a guest that question of
course i remember thinking
i wonder if i could tell that story yeah
if that is an offensive joke or not no i
think it worked i think it worked of
course it worked yeah it was wonderful
and i'm glad you did it and i'm glad you
listened to the show and
would you say
would you say it that felt rushed
sam
yeah thank you thank you would you say
you know i'll say it
keep it
you don't have to okay i'm just
would you say the pete holm show the p
oh i missed the pete home show oh man i
wasn't going to talk about it it was
really fun it was super fun and uh this
is the backdrop
hey i'm taking it home yeah i mean
no i'm gonna keep it
i'm going to keep that's what you think
it lights up
hey pete yeah keep it crispy
god
perfect let's do it again remember
you're a little jewish nothing
from what are we not rolling on that at
all do we have to do it all over again
because we love making podcasts
[Music]
you